nous commencions et que nous reprenions
nos travaux de de commission non sans
vous souhaiter bien entendu puisque nous
sommes dans la période à chacun d'entre
vous une bonne année et à notre
commission évidemment une année remplie
et chargée je ne doute pas d'ailleurs
qu'elle le qu'elle le sera et on va
commencer tout de suite par un thème qui
évidemment va va marquer l'année celle
le thème des des Jeux Olympiques avant
toutefois de parler des des de la
préparation des Jeux Olympiques et
paraolympiques nous avons une
désignation à faire de rapporteur ça va
durer 30 secondes vous me
permettez de rapporteur pour la
proposition de loi sur
le sur le cinéma suite à à au rapport
qu'avait réalisé il y a quelques mois
dont on se souvient bien entendu Jérémy
Biss son la provuté Céline boulet
espéronier rapport qui a été suivi d'une
proposition de loi qu'ils ont déposé
tous les trois euh pendant l'été et
cette PPL sera débatue en séance le 13
février prochain donc très prochainement
et je vous propose compte tenu de la
façon dont a été élaboré ce ce ce
rapport et l'implication très forte des
auteurs du du du rapport et de la PPL de
désigner Jérémy B qui se la prooté comme
rapporteur ainsi que euh Alexandra
borquio Fontain pour succéder à euh
Céline boulet espéronier si il n'y a pas
d'opposition il en est ainsi
décidé donc nous allons aborder notre
sujet de
jour pour reprendre nos travaux de
commission
avec cette année qui sera placée sous le
signe de de l'olympis nous avons le le
plaisir d'accueillir de personnes que
nous avons plusieurs fois l'occasion
d'accueillir ici même Michel cadeau
délégé interministériel aux Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques 2024 et
président de l'Agence nationale du sport
ainsi que Nicolas Ferrand directeur
général exécutif de la société de
livraison des ouvrages olympiques
messieurs soyez les les bienvenus au
sein de la commission de la culture de
l'éducation de la communication et du
sport puisque nous avons compléter
l'intitulé de de de notre commission il
y a quelques semaines vous êtes bien
placé pour savoir que nous ent dans la
dernière ligne droite de la longue phase
de préparation des 33e Jeux olympiques
d'été le président de la Cour des
comptes a parlé en en beau français de
mononeytime lors de son audition non
sans avoir indiqué que que la plupart
des voyants étaient au au vert il
estimait que les délais d'organisation
seraient tenus que les coûts seraient
sans doute maîtrisés il a constaté que
la livraison des ouvrages olympiques
allaent bon train et que les sites
pouvaient désormais être préparés à
accueillir
les épreuves la multiplicité des enjeux
et des intervenants implique bien
entendu un un travail de de coordination
considérable qu'on imagine d'autant plus
important dans cette dernière ligne
droite vous nous direz sans doute quels
sont vos principaux points de vigilance
pour les les prochains mois sur cette
question justement de la la coordination
nous sommes bien entendu également
intéressé comme bon nombre de nos
concitoyens outre l'évolution des coûts
d'organisation que j'ai é voqué à
l'instant et pour lequel les annonces ou
plus exactement les articles parus dans
la presse hier montrre que le sujet est
encore très
évolutifs nous sommes évidemment
intéressés par les questions de coût
mais aussi les questions associé à la à
la sécurité et au transport nous
cherchons enfin n nous assurer en tant
que membres d'une chambre tourné vers
les territoires que ces jeux concernent
un maximum d'entre eux c'est un enjeu
que nous avions bien identifié il y a
plusieurs mois et pour lequel nous avons
toujours des interrogations beaucoup on
ont bien entendu souhaité accueillir des
épreuves des entraînements ou des
délégations sportives d'autres verront
passer la flamme olympique qui rejoindra
Marseille depuis Athènes le 8 mai
prochain et traversera ensuite plus de
400 villes françaises pendant 68 jours
elle passera d'ailleurs ici au Sénat le
14 juillet prochain mais des
interrogations persistent sur les
retombées effectives de cet événement
sur les territoires concernés et leur
population en un mot sur l'héritage
laisser par par ces jeux pour l'ensemble
du pays nous comptons donc aujourd'hui
sur vous à 6 mois de l'échéance euh pour
lever ses interrogations et nous
éclairer sur vos réalisations et vos
perspectives pour ces prochains mois
décisifs pour le succès de cette
événement que l'on aimerait à la fois
planétaire et local je vais vous donc
vous laisser la parole messieur pour des
interventions liminire d'une quinzaine
de minutes à l'issue desquelles je
donnerai la parole à ensemble de nos
collègues en commençant par nos deux
rapporteurs de la mission d'information
Claude Kerne et Jean-Jacques losac
corapporteur de la mission d'information
de la commission consacrée aux Jeux
olympiques et paraolympiques je rappelle
enfin à chacun que cette audition fait
l'objet d'une captation vidéo
retransmise en direct sur le site
internet du Sénat et consultable ensuite
en vidéo à la demande je ne sais pas qui
commence est-ce que c'est vous monsieur
cade Monsieur Merci monsieur le
Président messieur rapporteur mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs je suis très
heureux de me retrouver devant votre
commission au côté de Nicolas Ferrand et
de de vous retrouver en ce début d'année
2024 qui est évidemment une année
essentielle pour la bonne réussite de
nos jeux je vais essayer d'être assez
rapide dans la présentation que je vais
faire de l'état dans lequel nous nous
trouvons en ce début d'année
2024 avec d'abord une une fin d'année
2023 dont je peux considéré qu'elle
s'est terminé dans des conditions
correctes en ce qui concerne la
préparation des jeux pour la solideo et
le le point en sera fait de manière
détaillée par Nicolas Ferrand une
livraison des principales
infrastructures qui est parfaitement
dans les temps et dans les budget aux
indices d'évolution du BTP
prês déjà un assez grand nombre
d'ouvrages ont été livrés et les autres
le seront dans des délais normaux et
c'est quelque chose d'assez rare Nicolas
Ferrand le développera voudrais insister
sur le fait qu'on a eu sur la fin de
l'année 2023 quelques préoccupations
dont la presse s'est souvent fait l'écho
sur le Grand Palais sur la piscine de
colombe à Tahiti sur thaupo peut-être à
châteurou dont le site avait été choisi
plus tardivement pour les épreuves de
tir tous ces points ont été réglés avec
des feuilles de route très claires
partagés avec les acteurs locaux et on
est aujourd'hui sans inquiétude sur ces
points enfin le bilan pour les pour les
toutes les infrastructures et le travail
que que coordonne ou que porte
directement la la
solideo le bilan est extrêmement
satisfaisant et nous le valoriserons au
cours de l'année 2024 et dans les les
mois qui vont suivre en terme d'emploi
de de personnes en en en insertion si je
peux dire professionnelle donc comme un
outil massif plus de 3700 personnes
auront travaillé dans les chantiers de
la solidéo des millions d'heures
d'insertion des des TPE et des PME donc
un bilan qui me nous semble en fin
d'année assez rassurant effectivement
que je ne contredirai certainement pas
le président de la Cour des comptes de
ce point de vue deuxièmement sur le COJO
sur le comité d'organisation des Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques là aussi une
fin
d'année nous donnant satisfaction par
rapport à nos enjeux de l'année
2023 un budget qui a été adopté en
équilibre le 11 décembre 2023 par le
conseil d'administration du cojot qui
prévoit simplement une augmentation des
dépenses de 17 millions d'euros
équilibré par une augmentation des
recettes correspondantes sur 4 milliards
4 on est donc toujours dans la maîtrise
budgétaire une réserve pour cette année
2024 qui est de 120 millions d'euros qui
reste donc conséquente avec une
prévision des risques possibles ou de
l'imprévu qui est piloté de manière très
resserrée par laadjop avec la direction
du budget de du du ministère de
l'économie et des finances euh des une
billetterie qui se développe dans de
très bonnes conditions pour les Jeux
olympiques ou les cérémonies que nous
suivons avec plus de soins pour les Jeux
paralympiques c'est plus éloigné c'est
ça vient toujours un peu plus
tardivement dans les dans les achats de
billets donc c'est un sujet à à
conserver en vigilance sur l'année 2024
pour le reste tous les contrats de
délégation ce qu'on appelle les event
delivery euh entities au au à ces
gestionnaires directs des jeux de la
livraison des jeux ils sont tous signés
désormais euh à la fin de 2023 tous les
contrats de location de sititees et donc
d'occupation des sites les viu les vs
use agreement euh sont également tous
signés ou en cours de signature en tout
cas mais ils sont tous arrêtés dans leur
modalités et leur coût euh on on est sur
la sécurité privée dans la la dernière
vague des appels d'offre euh la totalité
euh des contrats seront en terme de
contractualisation signé pour la
mi-février euh pour l'ensemble de des
sites qu'il soit directement opéré par
Paris 2024 ou qu'il soit délégué à des
event delivery entities en
résumé pour le COJO on est dans une
phase maintenant qui est en train
clairement d'être celle de la de la
finition de la finalisation de la
livraison opérationnelle tout ce qui est
planification contractualisation est
derrière nous et s déroulé dans de
bonnes conditions et je mentionne pour
simplement faire prendre la mesure de ce
changement de de date de cette dernière
ère ligne droite que vous évoqueiez
Président je rappellerai simplement que
il y a un an lorsque nous étions venus
vous rencontrer le cojot c'était moins
de 500 personnes qu'aujourd'hui ils sont
2000 à la fin de l'année 2023 ils
étaient 2000 ils seront 4000 en arrivant
au si j'ose dire au port du du mois de
juillet et donc on voit bien que ça va
se traduire par une approche assez
différente puisqu'ils
vont l'essentiel de leurs effectifs dans
les sites pour coordonner site par site
toutes les tous les aspects purement
logistique
d'installation de raccordement
énergétique et de conditions d'accès et
cetera site par site donc une une
approche renouvelée qui du côté de
l'État et je vais conclure sur ce point
en vous donnant no nos nos enjeux pour
les les prochains mois de l'année 2024
qui du C du côté de l'État évidemment se
traduit par un une un besoin de
médiatisation et d'explication sur tout
ce qui va être visible désormais qui va
être concrétiser sur le territoire euh à
Paris les premiers chantiers temporaires
vont commencer à être installés par
exemple sur la Concorde dès le mois de
d'avril pour les premières les premiers
travaux puis ça va évidemment être de
plus en plus visible euh et donc on a un
besoin clairement avec cette visibilité
d'explication de donner les éléments et
de faire connaître le sens de cette de
ce très grand événement et de ce qu'il
apportera effectivement au pays comme
vous le disiez pour l'État moi
j'identifie et je voudrais dans cette
présentation un peu
générale appeler votre attention sur les
quatre enjeux qui nous semblent encore
être le les les points de de vigilance
et de décision éventuelle d'arbitrage
dans les premiers 3 qu mois de l'année
2024 jusqu'à la fin du premier trimestre
vra semblablement disons même le la fin
avril qui est le moment où le relais de
la flamme va se déployer dans le
territoire français premièrement les
enjeux de sécurité vous y avez fait
référence
j'identifie quelques points sur lesquels
on a un vrai suivi et sans doute des des
un rendu compte devant les commissions
qui sera nécessaire parce que ce sont
des sujets délicats un la cérémonie
d'ouverture des Jeux Olympiques et des
Jeux paralympiques un défi vous le savez
en proximité avec que un accès gratuit
pour un grand nombre plusieurs centaines
de milliers de spectateurs avec des
répartitions de ces ces billets gratuits
tout cela nous je pourrais répondre à
vos questions c'est pour nous un vrai
enjeu et de sécurité et de fluidité de
l'apparade nautique et de qualité du
spectacle qui sera présenté et qui
marquera évidemment et et donnera un peu
le l'image que l'on veut donner à cette
à ce grand événement et naturellement
toute sa sécurisation sur l'ensemble de
ces aspects deuxième sujet c'est ce
celui de la sécurité privée et des
moyens que le secteur la branche de la
sécurité privée sera capable d'allouer
aux grands besoins portés par le cojot
et pour lesquels les contrats sont tous
passés et et et sécurisé d'ici la fin
mi-février fin février comme je viens de
le dire mais ça ne veut pas dire que
pour autant les agents de sécurité
privée sont au rendez-vous ça pose
d'innombrables problèmes de
d'accréditation pour ces agents de de
formation le gouvernement a mis en place
un plan de mobilisation de la sécurité
privée avec des financements
considérables plusieurs dizaines de
millions d'euros pour des crédits de
formation et pour des et pour ensuite
l'accréditation par le knaps ce plan se
déploie dans de très bonnes conditions
il y a plus de 9000 personnes qui sont
entrées en formation depuis le le début
de l'année 2023 et on est dans un
dispositif où le travail est bien engagé
3è et dernier point tout de même
essentiel en terme de sécurité c'est
l'articulation des chaînes de commande
ement très spécifique au jeu entre les
centres de commandement nationaux ce
centre interministériel de crise CNCS
qui avait été centre national de
coordination stratégique qui a été créé
pour la sécurisation pendant la coupe du
monde de rugby et et toute la chaîne du
CIO et du COJO le Main operation Center
et les dispositifs de sécurisation qu'il
sur lequel ils sont habitués et qui
correspondent à un schéma olympique
renouvelé d'Olymp dans olympiade et
qu'il faut adapter à au système assez
vertical assez gouvernemental qui est
appliqué en France notamment autour des
préfets et pour nous sur autour du
préfet de police sur la zone
île-de-fance donc voilà nos sujets je
sur le plan cyber le plan qui a été
prévu et présenté ici se déploie
correctement la lutte antidrone les
moyens ont été financé en loi de
programmation militaire ou pour les lois
d'orientation les plans de remédiation
sur chacun des risques sont pris en
compte nous sommes dans une bonne
avancée et la Coupe du monde de rugby
s'est bien déroulé c'est un très bon
test pour nous et il y a eu plusieurs
Test Event vous le savez sur l'été et
sur les derniers mois deuxième enjeu
c'est l'enjeu des transports et et je
dirais de l'acè de de de l'adaptation
des conditions de circulation
particulièrement en Île-de-France
pendant les jeux je me bornerai à
indiquer deux points sur l'offre de
transport collectif puisque c'est en
principe c'est l'essentiel des trafics
c'est de l'ordre de 600000 à 800000
personnes par jour supplémentaire venu
pour les jeux spectateurs titulaire de
billets euh on est dans un un schéma qui
est à peu près stabilisé avec un plan de
transport qui prévoira plus 15 % en
moyenne d'augmentation des capacités par
la RATP la SNCF et les autres opérateurs
de transport en Île-de-France ou en
France
entière de le toutes les zones pour
lesquelles on a des capacités de de de
transport qui vont être assez
contraintes la zone ouest avec le Parc
des Princes Le Rolland Garros où il y
aura le même jour pendant plusieurs
journées deux intersessions sur le Parc
des Princes deux intercessions sur le
Roland Garos avec des croisements de
flux des gestions de de de de de
mobilité extrêmement complexe à
organiser des moyens importants à mettre
en terme de facilitation pour rentrer
des et circuler dans les dans les lieux
de d'épreuve euh un plan national de
mobilité qui va être mis en en place
d'ici la fin mars au plan national qui
reprendra les les données de chacun des
sites et les et et naturellement toutes
les conditions d'accès dans notre pays
dans les aéroports dans les gares les
renforcements des moyens au postes de
contrôle frontalier et cetera et enfin
un un document qu'on appelle le TDM le
travel demand management qui est un
document de de gestion de la demande de
transport permettant d'informer les
Franciliens puisque là il s'agit
d'Île-de- France uniquement sur les les
conditions euh d'encombrement ou de les
difficultés d'accès sur certaines lignes
qui seront plus chargés que d'autres et
donc leur permettant de planifier leurs
Plan de Déplacement domicile travail
notamment ou pour d'autres enjeux de
manière anticipée puis ensuite de
manière g en temps réel pendant les Jeux
donc ce dossier des transports mobilité
est considérable et euh il repose aussi
sur des priorités pour nous d'
accessibilité des transports et
naturellement de bonne information des
publics troème sujet de de vigilance
pour les mois qui viennent toute la
question du dialogue social et de
l'acceptabilité
sociale des mesures impliquées par les
jeux et par la concentration des des des
contraintes que qu'ils imposent
dérogation au congé hebdomadaire dans
certains cas dérogation au au congés
report des congés annuels surtout ces
points le travail juridique est est
derrière nous euh vous le savez il y a
une modification du décret sur la sur la
durée abdomadaire du travail en
particulier les administrations ont mis
en place des plans de continuation
d'activités qui conduisent à limiter les
congé et à en interdire même le le la
prise de congé sur certaines plages
horairou plage de de semaine pour
permettre d'avoir tous les moyens au
moment où ils seront nécessaires donc
tout cela ne peut se faire que si les
les accompagnements en terme de de prime
de
d'indemnisation sont sont en place c'est
traité ministère par ministère en tenant
compte des statuts d'une part des
personnels et de leurs contraintes les
policiers les les services d'urgence
dans les hôpitaux et cetera et c'est
traité d'autre part par un dialogue
syndical dans les commissions de suivi
social les CSA de chacun des ministères
et le Comité de la Charte sociale canim
le MDEF et la CGT avec Bernard thbaau et
Dominique carlac comme porteur de cette
ce lieu de concertation donc pour nous
c'est une vigilance essentielle que tout
cela se se traite dans un véritable
dialogue social intégrant les éléments
euh qui remonteront de toutes ces et les
budgets nécessaires qui remonteront de
ces concertations dernier point dans
cette présentation rapide et générale la
question de
de l'acceptabilité sociale et dans les
Territoires vous y faisiez référence
monsieur le Président Lafond de cet
événement et de ses contraintes donc une
véritable un héritage finalement des
jeux et une bonne mobilisation populaire
effective et comprise et donc faire
passer ces messages dans cette phase
d'accélération et de concrétisation de
la préparation des
Jeux héritage l'héritage matériel le
Nicolas Ferran en le présentera mais il
sera réel dans le département de la la
scène saint-enis il sera réel à
Marseille avec notamment toute cette
marina qui a été complètement euh
requalifiée il le sera à châteurou il le
sera à Lille il le sera évidemment dans
d'autres territoires également un
héritage immatériel avec les enjeux euh
qui aujourd'hui vont être renforcés sur
les derniers mois de de pratique
sportive notamment à l'école les 30
minutes d'activité physique à l'école
euh le bien entendu tout ce qui lève de
l'inclusion des clubs sportifs et et des
nouveaux équipements le plan 5000
équipements qui se termine et qui a été
un très grand succès et pour lequel il y
a un nouveau plan annoncé par le
président de la République et financé
dès
2024 baptisé plan 2000 génération 2024
équipement 2024 des emplois sportifs en
plus grand nombre il y a eu 1000 emplois
qui sont recrutés pour l'année 2024 tout
ça permettra de participer avec les
clubs les collectivités dans des projets
euh de de pratique sportive en 2024
accompagnant les jeux et avec
particulièrement pendant l'été un
dispositif d'été olympique assez massif
pour les jeunes qui ne quitteront pas
qui resteront sur place enfin je
voudrais insister sur l'héritage
immatériel dans le sur le handicap et
donc dans l'inclusion effective des
personnes en situation de handicap
changer le regard et donc avec une
présentation pour dans les Jeux
paralympiques qui sera exceptionnelle
puisqu'il y aura plus de 300 heures de
diffusion gratuite donc sur la chaîne
publique permettant de mieux comprendre
et de mieux prendre la mesure de ce que
signifie d'être être un athlète ou un
sportif en handicapé en situation de
handicap euh nous enfin nous avons
développé les 40 14 études d'impact qui
permettront après coup après les Jeux de
mesurer efficacement l'impact économique
social environnemental euh de des jeux
dernier point je je veux je conclurai en
en en soulignant la montée en charge de
plus en plus visible aujourd'hui de la
mobilisation des territoires et de la
mobilisation populaire mobilisation des
territoires c'est le relais de la flamme
à très court terme évidemment de 15000
relayeurs 11000 déjà choisis vous l'avez
vu ça a été annoncé dans la presse un
dispositif de suivi de sécurité qui est
mis au point autour des préfets avec les
élus qui accueillent dans leur villees
et les départements les conseils
départementaux la billetterie populaire
je veux simplement insister parce que ça
concerne tous les territoires 400000
billets gratuit pour assister aux Jeux
olympiques ou aux Jeux paralympiques
100000 de ces billets pour les Jeux
Olympiques 300000 pour les Jeux
paralympiques et sur ces 300000 de des
Jeux paralympiques euh un grand nombre
de ces billets sont dédiés aux élèves
des écoles des collèges et des lycées de
tous les départements français euh qui
euh par groupe de 30 avec leurs
encadrants se rendront euh dans des
épreuves euh en dehors de leur région
souvent en Île-de-France assez
fréquemment puisque c'est là qu'ell se
concentre euh et qui bénéficieront donc
de billets gratuits euh et de conditions
d'accès avec la SNCF euh mise en place
et pour certains même de besoins
d'hébergement s'ils ne peuvent pas
rentrer le soir même et s'il est
souhaitable qu'ils puissent avoir une
deuxème épreuve gratuite le lendemain
leur permettant de de séjourner et de
repartir le lendemain tout ça se met en
place et donnera une une capacité de
participation collective
effective tout à fait nécessaire et
enfin vous le savez les clubs 2024 son
qui sont en train d'être agréés
dépassent aujourd'hui le chiffre de 200
on en a près 250 euh les territoires se
mobilisent de plus en plus pour assurer
part de ses fan zones finalement
labelliser une diffusion très large des
jeux voilà quelquesunes des mesures mais
il y en a plusieurs autres en terme de
de de
valorisation territorial et populaire
dont on pourra parler dans les questions
si vous le souhatiez merci beaucoup
monsieur préfet Nicolas F merci monsieur
le Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs alors j'ai une présentation
que puisque ce qu'on fait matériel et
donc on peut
l'incarner je vais non alors ça re dans
l'autre
sens voilà quelques pour commencer vous
connaissez cette l'organisation qui a
été mise en place pour la la livraison
des jeux d'un côté et au centre
évidemment Paris 2024 qui est là pour
réaliser l'événement et puis la Solido
société livraison des ouvrages
olympiques donc une une entreprise
publique qui est là pour construire tous
les les ouvrages nécessaires pour les
jeux et qui ont une vie après les jeux
comme je le dis souvent nous on
construit le théâtre et les équipes de
Tony est estanguer mettent le décor et
jouent la pièce
alors euh on a cette singularité en
France d'avoir un écosystème assez
complexe pour pour livrer les jeux 13
cofinanceurs on a l'habitude c'est
souvent le cas dans dans le cas des
contrats de projet par contre 31 m
d'ouvrage différents donc
31 structure qu'ell soit publique ou
privée en charge de effectivement
piloter les les travaux la solidéo dans
tout ça ayant pour mission de garantir
que quoi qu'il advienne tous les les
ouvrages seront livrés dans les temps et
dans les temps c'est le le le le 31
décembre 2023 pour la fin des travaux la
la transmission à Paris 2024 commencera
à partir du 1er mars ce planning que
vous avez là est inchangé depuis 2017
c'est-à-dire que on a absolument
respecter et passer tous les jalons dans
les temps le 31 décembre dernier 85 %
des travaux étaient achevés on est
actuellement dans la phase verte claire
que vous avez sur l'écran de lever des
réserves de manière à pouvoir commencer
à Trans transféré au COJO à partir du
1er mars et entre le 1er mars et pour
les derniers ouvrages début juin après
le les jeux ont lieu donc sur le l'été
2024 et on revient à à l'issue des Jeux
paralympiques pour faire ce qu'on a fait
les travaux de réversibilité de
conversion de ces différents ouvrages
pour qu'ils puissent avoir leur format
définitif leur vie après les
jeux alors qu'est-ce que nous avons à à
nous avons 70 ouvrages olympiques à la
fois des rénovations et des des ouvrages
neufs je vais vous en en présenter
Lestat d'avancement d'un certain
nombre le l'essentiel se passe
effectivement en Île-de-France
singulièrement en sa sainni mais
également dans les hautes scènes dans
les ivelines dans Paris à Marseille et
vous avez beaucoup d'équipements sportif
de AC mais également un nom de travaux
d'infrastructure cette petite carte pour
vous montrer où nous en sommes euh vous
voyez que la que tous les travaux sont
soit en cours soit terminés donc nous
sommes comme comme annoncé dans le dans
les timing et plus spécifiquement pour
commencer par le plus gros le plus
compliqué le le village des athlètes
alors cette vue nous sommes à droite sur
saint-toin à gauche sur Saint-Denis et
sur l'île sur la commune de l'île
saint-is puisque le village olympique
s'étend de part et d'autre de la scène
ce que vous avez sur le côté
complètement à gauche c'est l'autoroute
à 86 et le Stade de France qui est à peu
près au niveau du est du village des
athlètes l'ensemble des travaux de de
bâtiment s'organise autour de la cité du
cinéma que vous avez au centre cette
grande nef allongée avec les les boîtes
noires qui sont des des studios il
s'agit de pouvoir accueillir pendant les
Jeux Olympiques 15000 athlètes pendant
les paralmpiques 9000 athlètes et après
parce que ce projet est déjà pensé pour
l'héritage 6000 nouveaux habitants et
6000 nouveaux salariés à l'occasion de
de ce projet on fait un nouveau point
sur la scène c'est celui que vous vous
avez je ne sais pas si on oui on voit le
pointeur ici on réorganise tous
leschangeurs autoroutiers qui est ici
autour de playal on fait 7 hectares de
d'espace vert enfin on a on a un
programme complet pour faire un quartier
complet alors où en sommes-nous
aujourd'hui vous avez une vue de
drone tel que c'était en novembre 2023
aujourd'hui donc vous voyez que le le la
cité du cinéma au centre de cette de
cette vue les lots de ici et là qui
logeront des athlète ici également donc
là-bas c'est ICAD ne City et Vincy qui
construisent le le et vous voyez le le
niveau d'achèvement dans lequel dans
lequel nous étions au mois de novembre
aujourd'hui tous les bâtiments tous les
bâtiments sont terminés on est dans la
phase de leverée de réserve des des
différents bâtiments et la ceidéo achève
les espaces publics maintenant que les
échafaudages et que les bases de
chantiers des différents constructeurs
ont
été
démontés plus spécifique iquement au
mois de décembre vous avez la partie
donc Icade vous vous voyez donc la
diversité architecturale que nous avions
souhaité mettre en place puisque nous
sommes le le premier méga événement
mondial après toute une série
d'événements mondiaux asiatiques
pourutant que Dubaï soit soit en Asie
mais donc les Jeux de Tokyo les jeux de
pyongchang les jeux de de Pékin
l'exposition universelle de Dubaï donc
il s'agissait de montrer un autre modèle
urbain finalement au monde qui va venir
nous visiter et nous nous avons pensé
singulièrement que le la qualité
architecturale et la qualité des espaces
publics était une marque de distinctive
de la ville européenne l'ensemble des
rez-de-chaussées que vous voyez
excusez-moi l'ensemble des réés que vous
voyez sur cette vue ici sera occupé par
des commerces après les jeux et pendant
les jeux seront upé occupé par
différents services pour les athlètes et
apportés par les délégations
nationales le village des athlètes c'est
aussi un certain nombre de d'espaces
publics et nous avons mis une attention
toute particulière sur les questions
d'accessibilité cette grande rampe ronde
permet de rattraper la différence de
niveau entre le le les rues hautes et
les rues basses ça permet de transformer
des questions d'accessibilité en objet
complètement urbain c'est aussi
l'endroit où les athlètes c'est la place
olympique c'est l'endroit où les
athlètes vont être accueilli donc c'est
la première chose que les que les
athlètes verront et donc on a ce rapport
entre la nature la scène qui est
derrière cet objet qui est extrêmement
si vous me passez l' expression
instagrammable et les bâtiments anciens
qui sont qui sont autour c'est aussi la
ville
européenne il a fallu faire un nouveau
pont sur au-dessus de la scène piloté
par le Département de CSIE le pont est
fini on est en train de faire les
plantations sur le pont est-ce que vous
avez devant vous ce sont les berges de
la Seine où on a retravaillé toutes les
berges pour faire cette avancée avec des
Estacades sur la scène de manière à
recréer un rapport entre le fleuve et la
ville et puis le village olympique c'est
aussi l'innovation parce que nous avons
des leaders mondiaux dans tous les
domaines urbains et donc nous avons
souhaité en faire un une vitrine de ce
qu'on faisait de mieux en terme en terme
urbain là ce que vous avez ici c'est
c'est espèce de soucoupe volante aspire
l'air sur le côté rejette un air
complètement dépollué par le trou
central c'est au cœur du village des
athlètes et nous en faisons des cas
d'usage pendant les pendant les Jeux ça
a également été déployé dans des écoles
autour du village des
athlètes le le autour du village des
athlètes les les athlètes vont
s'entraîner avant de partir pour leur
site de compétition et donc nous avons
rénové un certain nombre d'équipements
le plus emblématique c'est la grande
Nève de l'île des Vanes qui est sur
l'île Saint-Denis au bout de cette de
cette île mais qui appartient à
saint-toouin et donc qui a été
entièrement remise en état pour la
gymnastique les entraînements de
gymnastique rythmique comme vous le
voyez les la réception aura lieu en
avril et la prise en main par pr du 24 a
lieu au mois de juin il faut comprendre
que paris24 prend en main très tôt à
partir au mois de mars les équipements
dans lequel ils sont amenés à pororter
du mobilier à mettre des des ce qu'il
appelleent the look of the game c'est
des des repeindre mettre les le le le le
design des des des jeux et puis les
équipements qui servent juste
d'entraînement dans lequel ils n'ont
rien à apporter particulièrement ils les
prennent en main au mois de juin c'est
le cas de cette de cette grande
nef à côté du village des des athlètes
nous avons un deuxième très gros projet
qui est le cluster des médias nous
sommes à gauche au Bourget à droite à
Dunis et ce que vous avez en bas à
droite c'est le Parc des Expositions du
Bourget qui est transformé comme vous le
savez pendant les jeux en centre
principal des médias en studio
télévision géant 81 m² de surface de
plancher nous avons reconstruit dans ce
cadre-là un des halls le hall 3 qui a
été qui a servi pour le dernier salon de
de l'Air et de l'Espace du mois de juin
dernier donc qui est achevé et sur ce
site nous nous devons réaliser à la fois
le site d'escalade ici faire un pont
au-dessus de l'autoroute 1 que vous avez
là et réaliser un village pour les
journalistes appelé village des médias
ici où en sommes-nous aujourd'hui la
partie bâtimentaire est complètement
terminé nous sommes dans la phase
d'espace public donc vous avez le une
image de ce à quoi ça va ressembler le
là où vous voyez des poteau aujourd'hui
c'est planté d'arbres mais à l'époque ça
n'était que que des poteaux donc les
espaces publics sont en voie
d'achèvement dans la même idée prise en
main par Paris 2024 le 1er mars
prochain une autre vue de l'autre côté
réalisé ici par Soj
Prom et puis ce pont au-dessus de
l'autoroute à 1 qui est un pont en bois
du Morvent transformé dans le dans le
Jura avec une série dans dans le Jura et
c'est important pour la filière bois
parce que on refait des ouvrages en bois
au-dessus des autoroutes alors que
jusqu'à présent euh les les ingénieurs
autoroutiers dont je suis n'aimait pas
beaucoup l'alliance bois et autoroute
donc là aussi on ouvre des nouvelles
perspectives pour filiè bois comme on
l'a fait sur le village des athlètes
comme on l'a fait sur le cluster des
médias on refait tout le parc des sports
de la ville du Bourget de manière à
pouvoir accueillir dans cette grande
plaines dégagé ici le les le site
d'escalade donc vous voyez le le terrain
l'ensemble des des équipements sportifs
qui occupaient cette plaine ont été
déplacés on a reconstruit deux écoles
pour la ville du Bourger et
l'emplacement du futur site d'escalade
qui étant un site provisoire sera
réalisé par Paris 2024 aujourd'hui et
est prêt et sera livré cour en
mars à côté de des deux villages on a un
certain nombre de très grands
équipements le plus emblématique c'est
certainement le centre aquatique
olympique réalisé par les métropole du
Grand Paris en face du stade de France
donc là on est côté Stade de France à
cette occasion là on a réalisé un pont
sur ce ce grand fleuve urbain qui est
l'autoroute A1 et vous avez la piscine
derrière avec une vue intérieure de la
piscine les bassins aujourd'hui sont
sont en eau les 5000 sièges sont en
place c'est une piscine qui servira pour
le plongeon et pour la natation
synchronisée euh et pour un certain
nombre de phases du water polo et ce que
vous avez au milieu sont des parois
mobiles puisque en héritage il a été
souhaité de pouvoir diviser cette
piscine pour pouvoir plus voir plusieurs
ouvrag plusieurs usages simultanément
dans la piscine donc là aussi cette
piscine va être achevée avec un mois
d'avance elle va être achevée début mars
pour une prise en main par le cojot
début avril l'Arena Porte de la Chapelle
donc c'est une Arena de 9000 places le
le modèle c'est des Arenas c'est Bery
hein beri 20000 places la eu Arena des
France 40000 là on a une 9000 plac qui
manquaient en Île-de-France les travaux
sont finis on est dans la phase de levée
de réserve le premier match aura lieu le
11 février la mise en en à disposition
de Paris 2024 le 26 avril prochain donc
le cœur de l'histoire c'est l'Arena qui
est là et à cette occasionl la ville de
Paris a souhaité réaliser un certain
nombre d'équipement de proximité et
notamment de gymnases que vous voyez
dans les boîtes sur le
côté et vous voyez l'intérieur de de
l'Arena le dimensionné pour pouvoir
accueillir singulièrement le Paris
Basket Club qui sera le club résident
là-bas le stade départemental Liv du
manoir a été achevé au mois de décembre
le président siifreddy qui en est le
maître d'ouvrage a souhaité faire une
petite cérémonie qui a été reprise dans
la presse et donc c'est ça sera transmis
à Paris 24 au mois d'avril prochain HL
encour dans les Yvelines donc c'est
l'ancienne colline de déblé de de
Saint-Quentin qui est là sur lequel la
végétation a repoussé 40 ans après dans
lequel on aménage des usages pour le le
VTT la piste de VTT olympique que vous
voyez tracer là et puis ensuite des
pistes de VTT c'estàd que on organise un
usage qui préexistait dans sur ce
lieu-là et donc là aussi le Test Event a
eu lieu au mois de juillet dernier et on
est en train de faire les petits travaux
d'ajustement à après cette cette épreuve
test qui permet de vérifier la parfaite
adéquation de ce qu'on a fait par
rapport aux besoins là comme vous vous
pouvez l'imaginez l'arrivée est en bas
avec l'ensemble des dans la dans la
plaine dans la partie basse l'ensemble
des équipements euh qui seront là et
ensuite évidemment Marseille Marseille
là aussi on a eu un Test Event au mois
de juillet dernier sur il s'agit de
reconstruire six bâtiments avec les
trois premiers bâtiments qui était fini
et qui ont reçu les félicitations le
satisfait site de la Fédération
Française de voil les trois derniers
bâtiments seront réceptionnés à la fin
du mois pour une mise euh à disposition
de Paris 2004 au mois
d'avril alors le Stade de France
pourquoi est-ce que je mets cette image
là parce que la très grande singularité
des jeux de Paris c'est qu'on ne
reconstruisse pas de de stade olympique
ce qui nous permet de faire une économie
de près d'un milliard et demi c'était le
coût du stade à Tokyo on on rénove ce
qui doit être rénové de ce stade en
investissant à peu près 50 millions
d'euros donc ce sont les écrans c'est
l'éclairage c'est des choses que les
spectateurs voient moins comme le poste
de de commandement euh opérationnel
comme les salles pour les journalistes
l'ensemble du stade ayant été très bien
conçu dans les années 95 et à 98 donc il
y avait pas besoin de le démolir et de
le
reconstruire au total on va
construire notamment pour tout ce qui
est entraînement h piscines vous avez
par exemple en haut à droite la piscine
George valeray qui est la grande piscine
de 1924 qu'on qu'on rénove trois écoles
un lycée euh cinq ponts sur à la fois
sur la scène sur les Canau et sur
l'autoroute à 1 un échangeur autoroutier
qu'on reconfigure complètement et un
certain nombre d'autres objets ça c'est
l'héritage matériel de ce que nous
faisons alors Monsieur le Délégué on a
dit un mot il y a TR dans ce dans ce
panorama il y a trois sujets qui sont
sous une surveillance
particulière sur la partie ilenne du
village
olympique le le groupement de promoteurs
Picher le gendre doit livrer un CRE de
bâtiments pour accueillir
2700 athlètes et là-dessus on a 500 lits
donc pourant accueillir 500 athlètes qui
au lieu d'être livré le 1er mars seront
livrés courant avril au cojot donc là on
a un décalage de quelques semaines sur
le l'écoquartier fluvial mais nous ne
sommes pas inquiets on a un décalage de
quelques semaines sur le Grand Palais
sur le Grand Palais il y a eu un effort
extrêmement important par la réunion des
des musées nationaux qui est le maître
d'ouvrage pour se caler sur cette date
de mise à disposition du 19 avril qui
aujourd'hui est confirmé il y aura un
certain nombre de réserves qui seront
levées après le 19 avril euh qui sont
des réserves marginales et qui
n'empêcheront pas à Paris 2024 de
commencer ses travaux à l'intérieur donc
le Grand Palais sera opérationnel
pendant les jeux et enfin la piscine de
colombe qui est le lieu de
d'entraînement pour la natation
synchronisée aujourd'hui les plannings
devrait prévoir une livraison de cette
cette piscine début juin c'est c'est un
chantier qui a connu beaucoup d'avanis
et de de péripéties et donc on le suit
tout particulièrement pour tenir ce
calendrier là donc vous voyez on a trois
sujets sur 70 aujourd'hui qui sont
suivis sans de remise en cause à aucun
moment du du programme global qui est
qui nous avait été confié alors question
budgétaire on vous a mis cette frise qui
est qui est très dense mais pour vous
dire que le la mission qui nous était
confiée à savoir tenir les budgets hors
inflation exprimé en Euroc constant 2016
et donc que vous avez ici a été tenu
puisque vous voyez que le l'évolution
entre début 2018 quand nous avons été
mission i
1378 millions d'euros en Euro 2016 de
budget public pour transit en par la
solidéo aujourd'hui on va sortir sans
doute à 14illard 412 c'est-à-dire plus
34 millions d'euros plus 2 % d'évolution
hors inflation et donc le budget est
complètement tenu en partie en raison de
nouveaux ouvrages qui nous ont été
confiés singulièrement par exemple les
voies provisoires et en partie également
à cause d'un
sous-dimensionnement initial des moyens
de fonctionnement de la solieo vous
l'avez singulièrement en mars 2022 point
qui avait été mis en avant par la Cour
des comptes en disant que la solieo
n'avait pas les moyens de d'achever
sereinement ses travaux et donc dans son
premier rapport de
2021 donc le budget est tenu en Euro
2016 après évidemment on a subi
l'inflation comme tout le monde c'est ce
que vous avez au niveau des euros
courants à côté de cet héritage matériel
il y a un héritage immatériel et je
finirai là-dessus
on nous a demandé de de que le les
ouvrages ompiques incarnent une ambition
française et singulièrement dans le
domaine environnemental et incarne le
meilleur des savoir-faes Français le
village olympique aujourd'hui réduit de
47 % son bilan carbone par rapport à ce
qui se faisait en 2019 le village
ompique c'est plus de 300000 m² de
surface de planchée et ça on le fait
sans subvention
publique cet objectif de - 47 % c'est ce
que la stratégie nationale
bacarbone fixe comme objectif pour le
l'industrie la construction pour
l'horizon 2030 2035 et donc on l'atteint
aujourd'hui sans subvention publique si
on peut l'atteindre aujourd'hui sans
subvention publique et dans ce Calandri
extrêmement court dans lequel on est on
peut le faire dans toutes les
préfectures de France aujourd'hui le
principal héritage immatériel pour la
filière de la construction aujourd'hui
il est là ça veut dire que oui on peut
décarboner la construction on en est la
preuve on a travaillé sur l'économie
circulaire et singulièrement on on a
développé un bâtiment qui met en place
un d'innovation de rupture et qui permet
de recycler l'intégralité de ces eaux
grises et noires ce qui permet une
économie d'eau potable de près de 60 %.
donc au moment où on parle de contrainte
à la
sécheresse aujourd'hui on on a des
démonstrateurs qui ouvrent la voie pour
faire des économies extrêmement
substantielles en terme en terme d'eau
potable et puis on a pris en main la
question la résilience par rapport au
changement climatique et on a on a
vérifié que nos bâtiments seraient
confortables à l'été 2050 c'est-à-dire
sous la canicule de 2003 et là-dessus
sans climatisation on atteint un taux de
confort dans 97 % des pièces du village
olympique là encore sans climatisation
ça a été à la fois modélisé par Météo
France et par dasso
système cette démarche d'innovation elle
s'appuie sur un fond d'innovation que
vous avez ici qui a permis de de
subventionner 34 projets sur les 60 qui
ont été soumis pour un montant de près
de 36 millions d'euros et c'était un des
facteur de de réussite et à côté de
cette démarche de d'ambition
environnementale extrêmement forte on
nous a demandé d'avoir une ambition
sociale extrêmement forte 10 % 10 % des
heures travaillées sont dédié à des
publics loin loin loin de l'emploi on
devait faire 2,4 million d'heur
d'insertion on en est aujourd'hui alors
même qu'on a des encore des des travaux
à après les Jeux après de 2,7 millions
d'heures d'insertion c'est 3800
personnes différentes qui ont pu
bénéficier des ouvrages olympiques des
travaux olympique pour faire un un
chemin de retour vers l'emploi et donc
c'est bien que l'ensemble des ouvrages
olympiques profite au territoire ce qui
est vrai aussi au niveau des PME et des
TPE des structures de SS on devait faire
25 % en montant on en est à 38 % et le
plus important c'est c'est ça voilà
l'ensemble des entreprises qui
aujourd'hui participent aux ouvrages
olympiques 85 départements français et
je pense la plupart des vôtres mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs ont des des
PME des TPE qui aujourd'hui construisent
ou participent à construction des
ouvrages olympiqu donc c'est bien toute
la France qui construit aujourd'hui les
ouvrages olympiques enfin et c'est je
crois le un des sujets sur lequel on est
à la fois le plus fier et le plus humble
nous avons eu quatre fois moins
d'accidents de sur les les les chantiers
des ourales Olympiques par rapport à la
moyenne de la profession nous avons eu
169 accidents on aurait dû en avoir à
peu près 800 27 graves aucun accident
mortel et ça c'est grâce à la beaucoup
de prévention au contrôle de laadriette
de l'inspection du travail mais
également à une mobilisation extrêmement
forte de l'ensemble des entreprises et
vous voyez Sophie Binet a dit dans le
monde voilà il a reconnu dans le monde
le 13 octobre
dernier enfin la question du de la lutte
contre le travail illégal on a à peu
près 100 cas de travailleurs sans papier
qu'il soit non déclaré à l'URSAF ou avec
des ou irréguliers sur le le plan
administratif qui ont été identifiés à
rapportter au 3000 au 30000 compagnons
qui ont travaillé sur les chantiers
olympiques donc c'est extrêmement faible
c'est toujours trop mais c'est c'est
extrêmement faible et là aussi on a
déployé un certain nombre d'outils avec
en lien avec laadriet pour tenir cette
question du du travail illégal sur les
ouvrages
olympiques après nous nous avons une
suite euh aujourd'hui nous nous
préparons à reprendre les les travaux
après les les Jeux Olympiques puque nous
avons un certain nombre de travaux
complémentaires nous avons une école un
parc une deuxème phase du cluster des
médiia les permis de construire sont
aujourd'hui obtenus l'équipe aujourd'hui
la soido c'est 150 personnes une équipe
de 50 personnes 46 pour être précis fera
pilotera cette cette deuxième étape
notre PSE est en cours mais cette équipe
est en train d'être identifié et puis
les marchés sont en cours de rédaction
donc pour conclure aujourd'hui les
ouvrages olympiques sont absolument dans
les temps sont dans les budgets qui nous
ont été alloués et dans le niveau
d'ambition qui nous a été fixé merci à
vous merci Monsieur le Directeur
première question de nos deux
corapporteurs commençons par Claude
Kerne et ensuite Jean-Jacques
loszac merci président euh messieurs
tout d'abord je voudrais vous présenter
à nouveau des vœux à vous
personnellement mais également pour une
belle année olympique réussie merci pour
vos exposés qui étaient très complet et
qui laisse entrevoir je dirais la
réussite de ces jeux réussites que nous
souhaitons tous Monsieur le Délégué
interministériel nous vous avions
auditionné à la suite des incidents
survenus au Stade de France le 28 mai
2022 vous aviez alors souligné et je
cite une situation grave très
défavorable à notre réputation
internationale en matière d'organisation
des événements sportifs notamment en
raison d'une gestion des flux
déficientes pouvez-vous nous rassurer
aujourd'hui à ce sujet en nous
expliquant comment les recommandations
que vous aviez alors émises ont été
prises en compte dans l'organisation des
Jeux et ceci afin d'anticiper
d'éventuels problèmes de transport de
délinquence ou encore de billetterie
falsifié qui viendrait perturber l'accès
au site comme ce fut le cas au Stade de
France s'agissant plus généralement de
la sécurité et vous l'avez rappelé des
questions restent ouvertes le cojop
estime que 70 % des besoins en sécurité
sont aujourd'hui couverts et que les 30
% restants le seront dans les prochains
mois peut-on vraiment croire ces
prévisions optimistes connaissant les
carences de la sécurité privée
aujourd'hui les policiers mais pas queux
sont inquiets et demandent que leur
participation soit clarifiée de même que
les contreparties indemnitaires et
sociales qui leur sont accordés dans ce
rapport de juillet 2023 la Cour des
comptes
que nous avons rencontré hier avec
Jean-Jacques lausac demandait la
finalisation rapide du dispositifs de
sécurité avant octobre 2023 or à vous
entendre et à ce qu'on entend par
ailleurs nous n'y sommes pas encore
arrivés ne risque-t-on pas de devoir
combler dans l'urgence des besoins comme
ce fut le cas lors des Jeux Olympiques
de Londres en mobilisant notamment les
armées quelles sont vos attentes
vis-à-vis du ministère de l'intérieur ou
plus globalement vis-à-vis de l'État à
ce
sujet puis monsieur
Ferrand le très belel équipement comme
le centre aquatique de Saint-Denis
euh d'après ce qu'on a entendu ne répond
pas aux attentes pour les compétitions
de natation en
ligne parce que la jauge des spectateurs
est trop
faible pouvez-vous nous expliquer
comment cela est arrivé et quelles sont
les solutions apporté et éventuell
l'incidence sur le budget voilà mes mes
questions monsieur le Président
oui merci merci Monsieur le le Président
Monsieur le le délégué interministériel
Monsieur le Directeur je crois que le le
sentiment largement répandu c'est que et
vous l'avez confirmé ce matin les Jeux
Olympiques et
paralympique se présente plutôt bien
globalement si je peux dire même si ici
ou là effectivement il y a quelques
difficultés qui demeurent voire quelques
polémiques qui apparaissent de temps en
temps sur sur le prix de l'hébergement
sur le le prix de certains billets pour
la cérémonie d'ouverture ou bien encore
les les difficultés de déplacement bon
j'ai j'ai vincu la le le plan de
transport parce que je pense qu'il y a
un certain nombre de collègues qui vous
interpelleront là-dessus en matière de
de de mobilité bon sur le plan du
financement je dois dire que quand on
regarde les les observations du comité
d'audit du job il y a matière à être
plutôt rassuré hein d'autant plus ilil y
a quand même deux filets de sécurité qui
sont plutôt euh essentiels c'est-à-dire
la garantie de l'État et puis d'autre
part la réserve pour ala et vous l'avez
dit vous-même il reste à peu près 120
millions d'euros sur cette réserve pour
ala qui ne sera probablement pas
entièrement consommé et d'ailleurs dans
notre débat budgétaire autant nous
avions été très critique sur le
programme 219 c'est-à-dire le le
financement des politiques sportives
nationales autant nous avions été
conciliant pour ne pas dire approbateur
sur le programme 350 concernant en
particulier le financement de de la
solidéo et effectivement ce budget là
semble être véritablement tenu alors
bien sûr il y a des aspects pour nous
qui très difficiles à apprécier
concernant cette période c'est notamment
tout ce qui concerne la préparation de
nos équipes nationales mais ça ce sont
des volets tout à fait tout à fait
particulier alors d'abord une question
je dirais de portée générale à savoir
que à vos yeux semble-t-il est-ce qu'une
nouvelle loi olympique sera nécessaire
ou pas notamment au cours de de ce
premier semestre 2024 pour compléter
corriger rectifier l'existant donc
est-ce qu'une nouvelle loi olympique
nous attend ou pas deuxièmement sur le
domaine de la sécurité bon vous savez
qu'on avait eu tout un débat lors de la
loi du 19 mai 2023 autorisant donc à
titre expérimental jusqu'au 31 mars 2025
et unique pour les événements de de
grande ampleur le recours à des
techniques de
vidéosurveillance dit intelligente et
cetera bon ma question elle porte je
dirais uniquement sur l'aspect
opérationnel de de de ces techniques et
sur la faisabilité de leur déploiement
effectif pendant ces ces jeux est-ce que
d'après vous nous nous avons eu nous
nous avons ou nous aurons suffisamment
de temps pour véritablement tester
toutes ces technologies je dirais en en
condition
réelles donc donc où en sommes-nous sur
ces phases d'essai de déploiement de de
ces techniques sur le
financement alors vous avez évoqué la
Cour des comptes d'après la Cour des
comptes la dépense pour l'État ça sera
de l'ORD de 3 milliards d'euros à peu
près en bout de course mais la dépense
publique c'est aussi la dépense des
collectivités territoriales et
d'ailleurs nous avons demandé à ce que
dans le rapport de de la Cour des
comptes d'octobre 2025 figure la
globalité de la dépense publique et donc
à vos yeux justement puisqu'il y a le
financement de de terr de jeux de centes
de préparation de jeux de la flamme
olympique de tout un ensemble
d'animations diverses et variées d'après
vous à à combien à ce stade vous estimez
l'ensemble de la dépense publique pour
ces ces Jeux Olympiques et et
paralmpique et est-ce que vous estimez
prendre de nouvelles mesures
d'optimisation de la gestion des sites
ou de réduction des niveaux de servicees
bon il y a un comité interministériel
qui était prévu je crois pour le début
de l'année est-ce que ce type de de
décision de mesures étit
envisagé sur le programme héritage
olympique donc effectivement on est
arrivé maintenant à un document très
très ambitieux avec 170 orientations
stratégiques et danst le suivi incombe
justement à à la Délégation
interministérielle à laad jop est-ce que
d'après vous il y a quand même des
mesures sur ces 170 annoncé qui
mériteraient vraiment d'être priorisés
par rapport à d'autres est-ce que
l'ensemble des objectifs selon vous sera
atteint et est-ce que la la grille
d'évaluation qui est envisagée vous
paraît satisfaisante euh sur la
billetterie populaire donc 400000
billets 300000 pour les Jeux
paralympiques concrètement on voit quand
même apparaître je dois dire on a quand
même des difficultés qui remontent du
terrain on voit apparaître a Mme pas mal
de difficultés pour par exemple ces
jeunes venant des des territoires des
régions ne serait-ce que pour des
raisons de temps de trajet voir
d'hébergement est-ce que ce genre de
difficultés vous sont remonté et puis
enfin une dernière question un petit peu
plus précise
concernant les la mise à disposition du
Stade de France puisque effectivement il
va y avoir une perte d'exploitation une
perte de recettees pour le consortium du
Stade de France on estime ça à peu près
à 20 millions d'euros je voudrais savoir
donc ben où on en est dans ces dans
cette indemnisation des pertes
d'exploitation dans ces ces relations
notamment entre le cojop et puis d'autre
part le le consortium du Stade de France
merci
je vais vous laisser répondre à ces deux
premières séries de questions je le fais
sur les points qui me concernent plus
directement si Nicolas Ferrand a des
points complémentaires il le fera
également premièrement les suites
réservées aux incidents de la Ligue des
champions de mai 2022 et
particulièrement à la suite des
auditions et de vos recommandation comme
du rapport que j'avais remis à la au
ministre de l'Intérieur et à la des
outremèes et à la ministre ministre des
Sports et des jeux dès le mois de juin
2022 euh je crois que la totalité des
mesures qui ont été préconisés que ce
soit par les commissions parlementaires
ou par mon par le rapport que que
j'avais assumé ont tout été mis en place
de manière très détaillée et avec un
suivi
euh extrêmement précis de de la mise en
œuvre effective de ces mesures très
concrètement
euh le le le la priorité a été mise au
sein du ministère de l'Intérieur depuis
plus d'un an maintenant sur la mise en
place de plans baptisés zéro délinquence
par le ministre demander à chacun des
préfets sur tous les sites chaque site
donc un plan avec des affectation de
moyens évidemment des renforts
considérables qui ont été mobilisés pour
assurer cette présence de contrôle en
terme de lutte contre la délinquence et
et un des sujets sur la Ligue des
Champions c'était qu'il y avait beaucoup
de moyens mais qui étaaient des moyens
destiné à faire face à des problèmes
d'ordre public or le sujet était plus
celui de contrôler des euh des vols ou
des des petites attaques sur les
personnes qui attendaient pour rentrer
dans les locaux deuxième orientation
c'est celle évidemment d'une billetterie
sécurisée et et donc une billetterie
digitalisée c'est désormais le cas vous
là vous le savez pour tous les grands
événements il y a une circulaire de la
ministre des Sports qui a été prise à
cet effet à la fin de l'année dernière
au mois d'octobre ou de novembre et qui
s'applique désormais pour tout événement
d'une certaine dimension et
naturellement c'est le cas complet pour
le les jeux et pour la billetterie des
jeux donc on est dans un schéma qui de
ce point de vue est également
complètement sécurisable et sécurisé
enfin et c'est peut-être l'essentiel
parce que c'était la cause première de
ces difficultés c'est la mise en place
d'un
dispositif réactif et précis euh et en
proximité de circulation des flux entre
le la gestion des transports collectifs
des arrivées et les entrées dans le
stade et donc avec un schéma de suivi
d'accompagnement de ces flux de
réactivité s'il faut ajuster les
circulations pour éviter des
encombrements et des accumulations à
certaines entrées susceptibles de
générer à ce moment-là des incidents ou
des difficultés et donc ça suppose un
renforcement de la vidéo protection
autour des sites ça a été fait les
financements ont été alloués massivement
et les installations sont quasiment
toutes terminées particulièrement autour
du stade de France évidemment mais à
bien bien ailleurs aussi sur les
différents sites qui sont les sites
d'épreuve deuxièmement ça suppose de
recruter un continuum d'accompagnement
de bénévoles notamment ce qui sera le
cas pendant les jeux avec 45000
bénévoles côté cojot ça c'est pour
l'accès et autour du site et dans le
site l' application des collectivités
locales pour tout ce qui est le
cheminement sur l'espace public entre
l'arrivée du transport collectif et la
prise en charge par le par
l'organisateur de l'épreuve et enfin les
les opérateurs de transport qui
eux-mêmes recrutent massivement pour les
jeux des ces moyens ces moyens avec des
bénévoles ou des salariés de chez eu
qu'il prennent en volontaire pour
assurer ses renforts pendant la période
des jeux avec un guidage une signale
éthique et un accompagnement
identifi donc voilà les principaux
éléments j'observe que pour la Coupe du
monde de rugby on a eu un ou deux une ou
deux difficultés les deux les deux
premiers les deux premières journées en
province d'ailleurs pas du tout en
Île-de-France à Bordeaux à Marseille
dans un autre site une panne de de tram
ici une mauvaise signalisation et une
mauvaise compréhension de de touristes
étrangers qui ne savaient pas sur quelle
station il fallait sortir pour aller au
stade Vélodrome à Marseille du coup ou
un encombrement sur un seul point donc
tout ce dispositif a été immédiatement
corrigé et n'a donné lieu par la suite à
aucune difficulté donc on est dans un
dispositif qui aujourd'hui est rodé qui
est approprié par les opérateurs et les
responsables de l'État et piloté en en
temps réel et en proximité avec des
moyens d'information qui sont
parfaitement coordonnés deuxème sujet
sur la sécurité privée les 70 % 30 % ils
vont passer à 100 % de
contractualisation donc tous les
contrats seront à peu près tous passés
par le Paris 2024 ou ces ou ces
délégataires donc ça c'est un premier
point on sera dans dans cette situation
de sécurité contractuelle en février en
revanche ensuite vous avez parfaitement
raison on aura un un vrai défi de
mobilisation de la sécurité privée donc
des personnes là je peux vous donner
quelques chiffres l'objectif c'est
d'avoir en moyenne 18000 positions jour
puisque les calculs sont faits par par
des postes à tenir ces postes une fois
qu'on met en face une personne il faut
qu'elle soit disponible pour le le tenir
pendant 12h donc ça veut dire
éventuellement deux personnes si c'est
au-delà des durées de service normal
donc ce le ce calcul va est en train
d'être fait désormais sur les marchés
déjà passés sur les 70 % et et va l'être
de manière complète pour obtenir ses
effectifs moyens 24000 pour les Jos en
pic sur certaines journées 18000 en
moyenne et 8000 en moyenne pour les Jeux
paralympiques et 12000 ou 13000 sur
certaines journées pour les Jeux
paralympiques les plus chargés ça c'est
le l'objectif ensuite il faut mobiliser
en formant et en faisant agréer au
knaps les des des des agents
supplémentaires ce travail est en cours
il est piloté sur l'Île-de-France par le
préfet de région le Pôle emploi et
laadriets et avec des résultats qui à
date sont assez positifs puisque
l'objectif c'est d'avoir à peu près
28000 entrées en formation puisqu'il
faut évidemment renouveler également les
emplois qui sortent du secteur et donc
et 20000 pour l'île-de-fance aujourd'hui
en Île-de-France à fin novembre 2023 on
est à 9600 demandeurs d'emploi qui ont
bénéficié d'un recrutement dans la
sécurité privée et 15000 qui ont été
formés donc le les financement pour la
formation y compris avec un appui
significatif du conseil régional mais
l'État a largement pris sa part ont été
mobilisé les formations et les les
sessions de formation ont été organisées
et on a cette montée en charge effective
qui apportera une ressource ensuite
est-ce que cette ressource sera
effectivement affectée prioritairement
est-ce que les les personnes choisiront
d'aller travailler dans les contrats qui
sont ceux de la sécurité des jeux alors
même qu'il y aura des sollicitations sur
tout un une série d'événements de Fan
Zone de de de de de de de fête et de et
d'événements organisés par les
partenaires c'est une question qui
aujourd'hui ne peut pas être
complètement assuré il faut précisément
vérifier dans quelles conditions se fait
cet apparîent si possible trouver des
systèmes de réservation où les personnes
s'inscrivent et sont prêtes à s'engager
et enfin il faut sans doute faciliter le
dispositif d'accréditation pour ne pas
constituer un petit élément de
découragement pour les personnes privées
voilà sur ces points évidemment il y
aura sans doute à un moment donné à
faire un point sur la capacité
mobilisable et à peu près
sécurisée la proportion probable de no
show poss possible chaque jour qui est
quand même de quelques pourcent et les
besoins éventuels de mobiliser des
renforts de public mais c'est prématuré
aujourd'hui et l'objectif est de le
limiter au strict au strict minimum si
je peux dire ce recours sur les autres
points pour le financement je crois CIS
que monsieur losac a clairement indiqué
ce qui est notre position effectivement
sur le fait que cette réserve de 120
millions d'euros est importante mais
qu'il faut la suivre de très près parce
qu'on va rentrer dans une période où les
dépenses seront très difficilement
évitable il y a un certain nombre de de
travaux de d'aménagement qui devront
obligatoirement être fait au dernier
moment si on veut livrer et donc on aura
beaucoup moins de facilité de les
reporter les réduire ou les compenser
par d'autres par d'autres économies euh
est-ce qu'une nouvelle loi olympique
serait nécessaire et est-ce qu'elle
serait possible si je me permets de
compléter votre question dans le
semestre déjà engagé ce n'est pas
aujourd'hui une hypothèse sur laquelle
les services de l'État travaillent euh
il y aura sans doute besoin d'une loi
olympique pour 2030 pour les jeux
divivers certainement mais à court terme
nous pensons que la loi olympique de
2023 a permis de traiter l'essentiel de
nos de nos exigences euh le recours à
des techniques de vidéo intelligence la
loi là aussi a permis vous avez vu de
lister les cas d'usage permettant cette
ce recours à la vidéo intelligence sans
euh reconnaissance faciale le dispositif
a été testé déjà dans certains
événements récents dans des tests il est
assez euh assez positif dans ses
réponses on est un peu juste on le
savait à partir du moment où ce point
n'a pas été retenu dans la loi sécurité
globale il y a 3 ans euh et donc oui il
sera sans doute déployé de manière
limitée notamment dans des zones de
forte densité par exemple dans le centre
de Paris autour des sites et avant les
contrôles où il y a des risques de de de
où il y aura des probabilités
importantes de rassemblement de
population en nombre et donc ce schéma
peut permettre d'identifier s'il y a des
colis abandonnés et tout de suite àer
vérifier s'il y a des voitures qui se St
à des endroits où ce n'est pas autorisé
selon le la liste des garanties et avec
le contrôle très strict vous avez vu de
l'arrêté du préfet de police qui devra
être pris soumis à l'acnil enfin on a un
schéma extrêmement protecteur qui sera
mis en place enfin pour ce qui est de le
du total des dépenses de l'État pas
proprement parler donc du budget de
l'État c'est une demande constante de la
Cour des comptes nous ne sommes pas
capables aujourd'hui de le donner de
manière stabilisée puisque par que
précisément les moyens complémentaires
que l'État doit mobiliser pour les jeux
euh les coûts liés au au justement aux
indemnités aux
primes à des conditions de transport aux
hébergements le gouvernement a réservé
pour les forces de sécurité intérieure
actuellement plus de 25000 chambres ou
lit dans l'Île-de-France que c'est la
dijob qui s'est chargé de ce travail et
de que nous nous avons réservé pour les
Jeux Olympiques notamment dans des
internats de lycées de collèges dans des
résidences universitaires dans à la Cité
universitaire dans des grandes écoles où
il y a il a il y a des capacités pendant
l'été c'est moins facile pour les Jeux
paralympiques et donc aussi avec un
recours à certains certaines chambres
d'hôtel donc nous faisons ce travail
tout ça aura un coût pour assurer pour
loger les forces de sécurité intérieure
qui vont venir en nombre renforcer les
forces de la préfecture de police sur
l'île-de-fance donc on aura
effectivement de l'ordre de 30000 forces
de sécurité intérieure venu de province
qui viendront renforcer aux périodes les
plus chargées les moyens disponibles à
la préfecture voilà enfin sur l'héritage
et sur le Stade de France pour conclure
sur l'héritage je dirais simplement que
les 170 mesures on en a fait le bilan à
plusieurs reprises elles sont elles sont
assez bien tenues il me semble que dans
le cadre du de la Grande cause nationale
et des engagements que la ministre des
Sports et des jeux a affiché à la fin de
l'année dernière on a effectivement sans
doute intérêt à revoir quelqu quelques
mesures d'héritage je pense notamment à
la pratique du sport dans les
entreprises de tout le volet fiscal et
et social donc d'exonération de charge a
été pris à la l'année 2022 déjà mais en
revanche il y a sans doute des
incitations plus plus importantes une
campagne à prendre pour essayer de
faciliter ce déploiement dont on sent
qu'il correspond à une vraie attente
aujourd'hui et sur laquelle il me semble
que il y a peut-être matière à aller un
petit peu plus loin je je j'ai il y a
quelques autres mesures du même type
mais qui rentre de mon point de vue
plutôt dans le programme qu'a affiché la
ministre sur cette grande cause de
développement du sport en 202 24 dernier
point le Stade de France c'est le
le l'arbitrage est effectivement
aujourd'hui quasiment finalisé après des
discussions
extrêmement complexes lentes et à
rebondissement entre le consortium les
fédérations les contrainte de transport
que vous connaissez aussi et donc tout
ça abouti à un projet de convention qui
actuellement est en en face de de de
finalisation donc oui ce ce point
d'indemnisation sur la période des jeux
tenant compte des travaux avec Orange
avec sur la piste d'athlétisme de de
tout ce calendrier de travaux qui
rallonge aussi certaines périodes de de
non utilisation et avec des report de
certains matchs sur lesquels des
solutions ont été trouvées pour les
concilier avec les travaux ferrés qui
doivent être pour poursivi après les
jeux tout ça est à peu près stabilisé
désormais et avec l'accord de toutes les
parties et donc ce sera officialisé en
terme d'accord dans quelques je pense
dans quelques semaines en tout cas ce
travail a bien avancé et on est confiant
sur son
issue Nicolas
Ferran monsieur sénateur vous vous
m'avez interrogé sur ACC de la jauge
pour notation en ligne alors je vais
être obligé de faire un tout petit peu
de d'histoire si vous me le permettez
dans le dossier de candidature donc qui
est fait dans les années
201526 euh il y a l'idée d'une grande
piscine de 17000 places pouvant
accueillir la la natation en ligne en
face du Stade de France pour un coût
annoncé à ce moment-là de 110 millions
d'euros ça c'est dessier candidature euh
la France est désignée pour accueillir
les Jeux en septembre 2017 et à ce
moment-là le gouvernement missionne
l'inspection générale des finances et le
Conseil Général de j' conseil général
des Ponts mais conseil général de
l'environnement et du développement
durable pour faire un audit de de ce
dossier de de candidature et à ce
moment-là euh rend un rapport au
printemps 2018 hein 6 mois après
la qu'on soit retenu en disant ce
chiffre de 110 millions d'euros n'est
pas réaliste il compare par rapport à ce
qui s'est passé à Londres à Londres il y
en a eu pour à près 260 millions d'euros
et ce qu'on a vu ensuite à Tokyo c'est à
peu près 300 millions d'euros pour une
piscine de 17000 places et à ce
moment-là au printemps 2018 tous les
acteurs se réunissent et il apparaît à
ce moment-là qu'on a pas besoin de
manière pérenne en héritage d'une
piscine de 17000 pl place parce que il
n'y a que pour les Jeux Olympiques en
fait qu'on a besoin d'une telle jauge et
le le l'accord qui est passé en à la fin
du printemps 2018 et qui se concrétisera
par un protocole signé en présence du
Premier ministre Édouard Philippe c'est
de dire on ne fait pas de piscine
pérenne de 17000 places le COJO fera
construirea une piscine provisoire de
17000 places et par contre pour les
besoins à la fois du territoire et la
capacité à organiser des championnats
d'Europe de d'Europe il nous faut une
piscine de 5000 places cette piscine de
5000 places donnera le CAO la piscine de
5000 places permet de de de de tenir les
compétitions en ligne pour les
championnats de type championnat
européens qu'on a plus de chance d'avoir
que les Jeux Olympiques à nouveau donc à
ce moment-là donc ça c'est l'été 2018 et
donc la métropole du Grand Paris prend
la maîtrise d'ouvrage à ce moment-là de
de cette piscine 200000 places qui sort
aujourd'hui à à 147 millions d'euros
mais montant qui était stabilisé dis à
l'été 2018 au moment où on a fait cette
revoyure globale du dossier de
candidature le cojot donc je continue
l'histoire sur la partie 17000 places le
cojot donc étudie la faisabilité à côté
de de du CAO de construire une une
piscine provisoire de 17000 places et à
ce
moment-là apparaît l'idée alors je sais
pas par où elle arrivéit mais apparaît
l'idée que on pourrait utiliser la u
Arena
àan qui fait 40000 places pour
accueillir les épreuves de natation et
en 2020 la décision c'est une décision
COJO comme c'est du provisoire c'est pas
chez moi en 2020 la décision est prise
par le COJO de transférer le c'est la
les épreuves en ligne qui devaent être à
côté du CAO de les de les mettre à
nanter dans la la Arena ce qui fait sans
doute une économie pour le COJO mais ça
je ne connais pas leur compte et je je
veux pas m'engager là-dessus mais ce qui
montre aussi quelque part que cet
équipement de Lau Arena peut avoir
beaucoup d'usage et c'est une
optimisation dans cette logique de
sobriété dans lequelle on est c'est
vraiment une optimisation parce que ve
dire on a même pas besoin de construire
du provisoire pour accueillir des
grandes jauges la la modularité de la
modularité de la uarena permet de
l'accueillir donc ça s fait comme ça en
trois étapes dossier de candidature
rapport de l'IGF donc remise à plat des
besoins au lieu au vu des besoins du
territoire et ensuite départ vers la
vers la u Arena j'espère que j'étais à
peu près clair juste une précision pour
expliquer la méthode le protocole de
2018 de donc après le l'audit de du
dossier de
candidature de juin 2018 ce protocole a
été signé par une quarantaine de de
collectivités d'acteurs pour montrer que
tout cela se fait dans un dialogue
extrêmement danse avec tous les acteurs
il a été signé et validé par tous les
maires par exemple concernés par des
sites et donc cette révision du projet a
été un projet une révision collective
même chose si je peux me permettre quand
en
2020 il y a eu le choix finalement
plutôt que de créer un une piscine
provisoire à côté du CAO pour avoir
l'ensemble trouver la solution à
l'arenna la défense et ça a été fait
dans un cadre où les deux bassins
provisoires qui sont positionnés dans ce
qui est une are de pour plutôt pour du
spectacle ou pour d'autres sports ils
sont il a été également décidé qu'ils
seraiit transférés ils vont être
installés à Sevran et à Bagnol est en
accord avec les collectivités donc tout
ce travail de de de d'adhésion
collective à des à ce à ces projets
demande beaucoup de temps s'appuie sur
des compétences techniques incontestées
finalement mais est aussi sans doute un
des héritages des jeux si je peux me
permettre parce qu'il il il traduit une
approche un petit peu
inhabituel dans notre pays de réels
partenariats autour d'objectifs communs
pour trouver ensuite les solutions
économes et en tout cas les moins
coûteuses par rapport à à nos
objectifs merci alors vous êtes nombreux
à souhaiter poser des questions je vais
vous donner évidemment la la la parole
on va regrouper toutes les questions si
vous le voulez bien on commençant par
Michel Savin qui est également président
du groupe d'études sur les pratiques
sportifes et les grands événements
sportifs merci monsieur le Président
donc je vais être très court pour
laisser la parole à mes collègues euh je
vais pas revenir ni sur le ni sur la
sécurité ni sur les équipements parce
que les questions ont déà été posées moi
je vais poser deux questions messieur
Monsieur le Délégué inter ministériel on
parle de jeu populair euh je vous trouve
très optimiste lorsqu'on voit que les
prix d'hôtel sont multipliés par 3 ou 4
so Paris que les Airbnb sont en train de
flamber sur la région parisienne que
est-ce que vous pensez vraiment que les
les les Français qui souhaitent qui ont
acheté des billets aujourd'hui sont dans
dans la capacité de de pouvoir venir se
loger sur Paris à ces prix-là donc ça
pose des vraies questions moi j'ai
rencontré sur mon territoire des gens
qui veulent aujourd'hui revendre leur
place parce queils trouvent ça
complètement démesuré et donc c'est plus
des jeux populaires deuxièmement
toujours sur le logement euh
euh on va vous aveit évoqué le logement
des forces de l'or des agences sécurité
des volontaires
euh la réponse qui avait été
faite à cette question c'était que il
fallait voir s en avait un ami ou ou euh
un un un amis ou des parents qui
habitent Paris tout le monde n'a pas des
amis et des des parents qui habitent la
région parisienne mais ça concerne
surtout les volontaires donc comment ces
milliers de volontaires vont être logés
pendant cette période là et ma deuxième
question concerne plutôt l'actualité
présente l'organisation et le suivi des
6 derniers mois de la période où tout
doit être réglé rapidement pour la
réussite de C cette événement comment
Monsieur le Délégué interministériel aux
Jeux olympiques et paralympiques
envisagez-vous cette période avec une
ministre qui jusqu'à présent était très
présente et uniquement mobilisée sur les
Jeux Olympiques et les paralympiques
est-ce que cette nouvelle et je voudrais
bien une réponse est-ce que cette
nouvelle
nomination avec un très grand ministère
avec un très grand ministère et
notamment avec des enjeux importants au
niveau de l'éducation comment cette
comment risque comment allez-vous gérer
cette période et pensez-vous que ça aura
un impact sur le fonctionnement et
l'organisation de ces jeux
merci nous connaissons toute l'habilité
du préfet cadeau mais on va lui laisser
quelques minutes quand même pour
préparer sa réponse colombe Brossel j'ai
fait moins de 2 minutes monsieur le
Président merci monsieur le Président et
merci Monsieur le Préfet monsieur le le
directeur pour pour vos propos euh
rassurant et mes deux collègues
corapporteurs le le disaient rassurant
sur le fait que
nous allons tous vivre un moment
extraordinaire un moment qui n'arrive
qu'une fois dans une vie une vie de
français une vie de francilien
évidemment une vie de
parisien et c'est voilà des événements
absolument extraordinaire qui nous
attendent qui dans un monde où il y en a
bien besoin vont pouvoir faire vivre les
valeurs de l'olympisme les valeurs de la
fraternité celle qui était en tout petit
hier mais passons cette autre chose lors
de la conférence de presse du président
et bien on voilà on va avoir une
occasion incroyable de faire vivre la
fraternité dans dans notre pays et c'est
c'est un un beau moment qui qui
s'annonce mais pour que ce soit un beau
moment il faut en effet et plusieurs de
de mes collègues l'ont déjà dit que un
certain nombre de sujets soitent
totalement réglés et je vais me
permettre de vous poser quelques
questions sur les transports notamment
parce que les réponses qui ont été
jusqu'à présent apportées me me semble
parfois manquer de de précision euh deux
sujets d'abord évidemment la la
possibilité de rendre compatible les et
je pense aux franciliens et aux
Parisiens les transports du quotidien et
le fait d'acheminer dans des conditions
qui soient normales
sécures les visiteurs qui viendront voir
des épreuves je je vous dis ça j'ai
failli arriver en retard ce matin parce
que j'ai pris le métro comme tous les
matins et sur la ligne 5 des métros il y
en avait pas alors vous me direz on
était pas seul parce que manifestement
sur la ligne 6 c'était le bazar et sur
le rerd aussi ça c'est la vie
quotidienne des Parisiens et des
Franciliens mais du coup du mal à
comprendre dans les annonces qui sont
faites notamment en terme d'augmentation
de la capacité de service au regard des
flux de voyageurs attendus à comprendre
comment euh la compatibilité entre
transport du quotidien transport des
usagers qui seront parisiens et
franciliens pendant les Jeux olympiques
et paralympiques de qui se dérouleront
principalement à Paris et en scène
Saint-Denis comment est-ce que on arrive
à rendre compatible ce qui paraît très
honnêtement aujourd'hui difficilement
compatible pour rester tout à fait soft
dans dans mon propos alors j'ai bien
compris que les parisiens et les
Franciliens subiront la la hausse du
Pass Navigo notamment hebdomadaire ou
journalier voit pas très bien pourquoi
le ce cou-l devrait être prise en en
charge par les usagers des transports du
quotidien mais j'avoue ne pas avoir
compris comment on arrivait à rendre
compatible je le dis ce qui paraît dès
qu'on met un pied dans le métro le RER
tout à fait incompatible et puis je je
reviens parce que vous l'avez évoqué
Monsieur le Préfet sur la gestion du
pôle ouest euh Roland Garros Parc des
Princes sur lequel
euh il y a manifestement un sujet
d'adéquation entre l'offre structurelle
de transport vous l'avez évoqué rerc
ligne 10 ligne 9 et la
compatibilité de plusieurs épreuves au
même moment et une gestion des flux euh
vous nous avez dit pendant les les
intercessions des moyens importants
seront mis en place mais lesquels parce
que c'est enfin si les moyens c'est
juste de mettre du monde pour indiquer
le chemin et réguler les flux c'est bien
pouvoir monter dans un métro ou un RER
c'est
mieux pierre
ouyas merci monsieur le Président merci
Monsieur monsieur Monsieur le Préfet
pour la qualité de de votre présentation
moi je vais je vais revenir sur le
propos de ma collègue colombe
brussell pour pour rappeler quels seront
pour les collègues qui n'habitent pas
Paris les hausses des tarifs des des
transports pendant les Jeux Olympiques
le billet à l'unité passera de 2,15 € à
4 € et le carnet de 10ticket passera de
17,3 € à 32 €
voilà donc vous nous avez expliqué que
il y avait une augmentation de 15 % du
volume de transport ce que je vous
demande si est-ce que ce sont les
usagers qui vont payer ces 15%
supplémentaire parce que quand on voit
les chiffres on a l'impression que la
totalité du surcout va être payé par les
usangés j'espère j'espère que que ces
Haus ne ne constituera pas l'héritage
des Jeux Olympiques et que et que
derrière il y aura de nouveau des tarifs
qui sont acceptables donc dans le bilan
financier des Jeux Olympiques il faudra
bien évidemment inclure ce qu'apporte
les départements et je suis conseiller
départemental des hautees scèes et je
sais ce qu' a coûté la mise à niveau du
stade de colombe mais je crois aussi que
de façon tout à fait morale il faudra
inclure ce que les usagers des
transports parisiens vont apporter pour
pour la tenue des des jeux des Jeux
Olympiques euh les jeux payent les
jeux ça c'est le
discours la réalité on voit qu'elle est
tout à fait autre et je pense que c'est
important d'en prendre conscience parce
ce que vous l'avez dit il y a un
problème d'acceptabilité sociale des
Jeux Olympiques et que c'est un sans
doute un très mauvais exemple qu'on va
transmettre pour les villes les villes
suivantes de de voir la façon dont ce
principe les jeux payent les jeux ont
été contournés de de diverses façons
alors sur sur un ton plus plus Allègre
moi je je regretterai et je crois que ça
doit être mis aussi au bilan n des Jeux
Olympiques que que ça nous prive du
tournoi desstination au Stade de France
et que j'iraai pas ni à Lille ni à
Marseille pour voir jouer le cas de
France là a une petite déception
personnelle mais bon c'est pas grave
merci Monsieur le
Préfet Agier c'est vrai
elle est
partie Monique
deco oui je vous remercie
voilà je reviens sur les ambitions
initiales des organisations des des JO
qui était de réduire de moitié les
émissions de CO2 c'estd l'objectif était
de passer de
3,5 millions un objectif de 1,58
millions disant que les ces JO seraient
justement historique pour le climat vous
avez bien donner une estimation
concernant donc les opérations de
construction je voudrais savoir quel est
estimation globale donc du bilan carbone
de cesgos si vous avez des prévisions et
je reviens monsieur Ferrand est-ce que
vous étiez en charge de la fameuse tour
donc qui était prévue donc à Tahiti en
plynésie et comment se fait-il qu'il a
pas eu d'études d'impact
environnemental comment se fait-il que
en réalité il y a pas eu d'inventaire de
la faune de la flore et d'études
géologiques sachant que aujourd'hui vous
êtes revenu sur la tour originale en
bois me
semble-t-il quel est finalement le coût
de cette opération qui était prévu donc
en aluminium pour ensuite revenir en
bois comment seit-il qu'on nanticipe pas
les impactes donc environnementaux des
constructions et des projets merci Ahmed
law merci monsieur le Président tout
d'abord je voudrais remercier Monsieur
le Préfet pour cette
présentation j'ai eu l'occasion de
visiter cette semaine le chantier du
village olympique et je remercie
Monsieur Ferrand pour cette visite de
terrain qui a été
fructueuse c'est une véritable réussite
et nous en félicitons notre département
de la SC S sera directement concerné par
ces Jeux Olympiques ces Jeux Olympiques
et parolympique mais l'un des enjeux
majeurs de ces jeux et qui est très peu
évoqué c'est le devenir des centres
sportifs construits pour l'occasion un
plan de transition a-t-il été envisagé
et quels moyens seront donnés aux
collectivités pour entretenir et faire
vivre ces structures après les jeux je
vous en
remercie Adel
zan merci merci président d'abord je
voulais en profiter pour saluer mais
aussi féliciter même si nous sommes pas
encore arrivés à cette date d'ouverture
des Jeux olympiques mais l'engagement
exceptionnel Monsieur le Délégué
interministériel et Monsieur le
Directeur de la salido pour le travail
de préparation dans le cadre des Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques je le dis en
tant que sénateur de la scène saint mais
aussi en plus particulièrement en tant
qu'élu de Saint-Ouin qui a été eu à
l'aménagement à l'urbanisme pendant 3
ans et les images que vous avez pu voir
les photos je pense Monsieur le
Directeur de la solidéo qu'on pourrait
presque avoir un avant après pour se
rendre compte du tour de force on parle
d'un village olympique de 51 hectares
Mariepierre tu me posaer la question
c'est fonctionnel on a eu cette visite
de terrain effectivement lundi dernier
dans une ambiance glaciale je parle au
sens
euh s climatique du terme on a eu très
froid mais bon euh qui permettait
justement de prendre la mesure du
travail qui a été mené et ça fait partie
justement de ces de ces éléments je me
rappelle avec une c certain plaisir
notre première discussion avec le
directeur de la solidéo en 2020 juillet
2020 à qui avec le maire de saint-toouin
nous interrogions sur les délais la
capacité pour la solidéo de tenir ses
délais et votre réponse avait été il y'y
a pas le choix nous serons au
rendez-vous les athlètes ne viendront
pas en septembre ils devêtre ils doivent
être là le 26 juillet deux question pour
ma part une sur les enseignements tirés
c'est une discussion que nous avons déjà
eu euh le travail qui a été mené sous la
direction euh du préfet Michel cadeot
pour coordonner ses efforts ce travail
de de mise en œuvre euh au cours de ces
six dernières années euh c'est à titre
personnel je l'ai déjà évoqué la solidéo
devra à terme êre donc démantelé c'est
toute une expertise un savoir-faire une
ingénierie forte qui a été mise en œuvre
des profils euh extrêmement euh
impliqués pour être justement à l'heure
et au rendez-vous des avancées moi je le
soulligne sur les questions d'insertion
sur les questions de sécurité sur les
chantiers sur les recrutements euh pour
pouvoir permettre de de de de recruter
des personnes et qui qu'elles puissent
travailler dans de bonnes conditions ma
première question c'était justement sur
ces enseignements sur cette gouvernance
sur le devenir cet héritage on parle
beaucoup d'héritage matériel et
immatériel euh des Jeux Olympiques et
parolympique moi je pense que aussi la
solidéo a montré un savoir-faire une
excellence française cette institution
qui a tenu enfin bien sûr les Goos sont
en juillet mais les délais sont tenus
aujourd'hui euh en maintenant aussi des
enveloppes finan è qui était celle qui
était prévu ma question c'est comment
quel leçons quels enseignements et quel
héritage en matière de gestion de
coordination et de collaboration entre
différentes entités différentes
collectivités différents partenaires
vous tirez et comment poursuivre
maintenir cette cette j'ai envie de dire
cette cette logique ce travail cette
expertise dans dans la suite ma deuxième
question très rapidement c'est pour vous
Monsieur le Délégué interministériel sur
en tant que président de l'Agence
nationale du sport sur les questions des
équipements sportifs pour mon
département la scène saint-uni vous le
savez c'est le deuxème département le
moins bien doté en France métropolitaine
c'est le premier département
métropolitain avec le nombre de
licenciés le plus le plus faible et
c'est le département le plus jeune de
France donc il y a cette déconnexion
entre jeunesse volonté de pratiquer et
manque crant d'équipement sportif ma
question portait tout simplement sur un
point d'étape du plan 5000 terrains de
sport qui avait été lancé en 2021 qui
arrive à échéance en 2024 notamment pour
le département de la scène saint-li ù
face au déficit marqué par rapport à
d'autres territoires en termes
d'équuments sportifs une conven de
financement spécial spécifique avait été
signé je vous remercie à nouveau pour
votre présence et votre engagement
Contin continu pour la réussite de cet
événement Jacques
grerin merci président au-delà de toutes
ces félicitations communes de l'ensemble
de la commission moi je voudrais vous
interroger monsieur cadeau sur sur suite
à la à la Cour des comptes lorsqu'on
vous recommandait de de de pouvoir
garder 100 millions d'euros l'objectif
est accompli avec 120 millions d'euros
la première question c'est est-ce que
vous pensez encore il avoir recours et
que deviendra cette enveloppe post Jeux
Olympiques deuxème question sur les sur
l'intelligence artificielle vous en avez
parlé tout à l'heure sur le fait de
pouvoir sur les colis sur les voitures
et cetera je sais que la knil est très
réstiscante par rapport à cela est-ce
que vous l'avez expérimenter
véritablement donc lors de de la Coupe
du monde de rugby et quelle conclusions
avez-vous pu en tirer et trème et
dernière question sur le futur des jeux
du des villages olympiques euh sur
l'héritage en tout cas euh ce village
olympique construit dans différentes
villes de Saint-Denis fait face parfois
des critiques mais outre le manque
d'accessibilité du métro
prix du mètre carré qui reste
relativement élevé est-ce que vous n'ayz
est-ce que vous n'avez pas peur d'une
gentrification de ces villes populaires
merci merci monsieur le Président merci
monessieur pour pour cette ces
présentations euh je souhaitais revenir
et j'é la la la question de de ma
collègue Monique de Marco autour des de
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre
pour l'instant les chiffres les
prévisions qui avaient été esquissées
étaient de d'un/3 pour les déplacements
un/ers pour les constructions 1/3 pour
les activités liées aux Jeux olympiques
et paralympiqu est-ce que vous pouvez
nous donner un peu des chiffres plus
précis sur les réductions de gaz à effet
de serre euh les réductions des
émissions euh euh envisagé et puis vous
nous avez parlé de de de de de la
réutilisation d'un maximum
d'infrastructure existante mais qu'en
est-il des zones
artificialisées sommes-nous en capacité
de les chiffrer et quelle
compensation autour de ces zones
artificialisées et puis enfin
euh toutes les émissions ne pourront pas
être évitées et et devront donc en
partie être compensé est-ce que vous
avez mesuré ces compensations et quelle
place ont-elles dans l'avancement des
travaux et puis une deuxième petite
question sur l'hébergement d'urgence on
sait que de nombreux hôtels se retirent
ces dernières années du dispositif
d'hébergement d'urgence notamment depuis
2022 avec 5200 nuité perdu en 2022 et
une courbe qui continue d'empirer depuis
qui risque de s'empirer en en 2024
encore alors que le dispositif est au
bord de la
rupture avec notamment donc sur les
100000 places dans la région
parisienne 55000 en hôtel social donc
donc quelles sont les solutions
envisagées pour les personnes
vulnérables sans abri qui risquent de se
voir laisser sans solution pendant la
période des j
merci Alexandra borqu
fontin merci Monsieur le le président et
merci messieurs pour vos interventions
respectives alors je souhaite pas
spécialement vous interroger mais plutôt
vous livrer une réflexion au sein de
cette commission nous défendons bien
entendu le sport et ces grands
événements sportifs mais beaucoup moins
en tout cas pour notre groupe certaines
décisions notamment de l'exécutif
concernant l'hébergement sur ces jeux au
moment du dépôt d'ailleurs de la
candidature française d'accueillir les
les Jeux Olympiques il n'a jamais été
question d'expulser des des étudiants ce
que je regrette profondément en tout cas
soyons rassurés la ministre de
l'Enseignement supérieur a généreusement
annoncé que les 2000 étudiants qui
devront quitter leur logement recevront
100 € et de places pour les JO pas pour
la finale du somm je vous rassure euh
heureusement en tout cas dans mon
département des Alpes Maritimes on pas
nos nos étudiants quand on organise le
Festival de Cannes le MIPIM ou le
carnaval de Nice au sein de cette
commission nous défendons aussi l'accès
aux événements sportifs pour tous or
cela n'échappe à personne et je rejoins
l'idée de Michel Savin les prix des
billets à totalement fissurer l'idée de
jeu populaire alors euh euh même si
évidemment l'accueil de grands
événements permet aux professionnels du
tourisme d' tirer profit je regrette
qu'aucune voix euh dénonce euh aucune
voix nationale hein dénonce cette
flambée des prix non pas spécialement
pour le le les épreuves mais également
pour l'hébergement alors évidemment je
n'ai qu'un souhait au-delà bien sûr de
la réussite des Jeux Olympiques pour nos
athlètees tricolor mais également pour
l'organisation générale hein de cet
événement majeur pour la France espérons
qu'en 2030 lors des jeuxhers en France
et bien on en tire des leçons pour ne
plus entacher l'organisation des Jeux
par des polémiques nombreuses qu'on
aurait pu éviter afin de rendre au sport
et à notre pays le rayonnement qu'il
mérite Stéphane
Piednoir merci monsieur le président
ident merci monessieur pour votre exposé
j'ai une question qui concerne
uniquement les les Jeux
paralympiques du 28 août au au au 8
septembre c'est un sujet qu'on évoque
assez peu sur la billetterie
2800000 billets sont mis en vente le
dernier pointage qui avait été fait
faisait un état des lieux à 80 80 % des
800000 billets vendus acheté par par le
secteur public et donc majoritairement
l'état ça veut dire que seulement 200000
billets avaient trouvé preneur auprès du
du grand public si je puis dire où en
sommes-nous de la commercialisation de
la de la vente des des billets pour les
les épreuves paralympiques et quels sont
les moyens de communication qui sont
prévus pour essayer de d'amplifier le le
mouvement parce que les choses vont
venir assez rapidement les leur les
concernants merci nombreuses questions
je vais en ajouter deux toutefois l'une
sur la cérémonie d'ouverture vous l'avez
évoqué Monsieur le Délégué très
rapidement euh où on eston de la
réflexion sur la jauge on a entendu
plusieurs chiffres est-ce que la jauge
est fixée et puis il y a eu un débat sur
l'existence ou pas d'un plan B est-ce
que vous pourriez nous dire un un peu
plus est-ce que il y a vraiment un plan
B est-ce que le Stade de France peut
constituer un un un plan bvent et puis
deuxème question sur la baignabilité
alors ce n'est pas un équipement en tant
que tel mais pourtant c'est un lieu
enfin c'est un élément important pour la
tenue de de certaines disciplines où en
est-on là aussi sur les les conditions
de baignabilité de la la Scine et la
Marne et est-ce qu'il y a un plan B puis
que je crois qu'il y a quand même une
incertitude qui est liée à la
pluviométrie s'il y a une forte
pluviométrie la veille des des
événements que se passe-t-il dans ce
CASL
bienin voilà est arrivé si elle veut
poser sa question excusez-moi monsieur
le
délégué
merci merci Monsieur monsieur le
Président 1000 excuses j'avais un petit
groupe d'écoliers du du primaire qui
était en bas
alors pardon
public ne relançons pas la gueur
ici alors je voudrais pour commencer
donc évidemment très rapidement vous
remercier donc pour votre mobilisation
qui a permis donc de présenter fin
décembre 2023 dernier bilan des
différents chantiers des Jeux Olympiques
avec un très bon taux de réalisation des
travaux de 84 % concernant donc les 70
ouvrages et opérations d'aménagement
beaucoup de choses ont été dites donc je
vais aller directement à mes à mes trois
questions tout d'abord la première
question elle elle pose et je pense que
elle a été posée par les autres
également elle concerne en fait la
sécurité de la cérémonie d'ouverture
puisque je suis élue de Paris du 15e
arrendissement qui va donc s'étendre sur
un parcours de plusieurs centaines de
mètres de long de la scène et euh à ce
propos est-ce que vous pourriez nous
dire
donc si une jauge maximale de sécurité a
été définie et qu'avez-vous prévu en
fait pour contrôler les menaces qui
peuvent venir notamment des bâtiments et
appartements dans les périmètres
restreints à la circulation c'est la
première question la seconde concerne
toujours puisque c'est le vrai sujet
pour nous n'y a-t-il toujours aucun plan
B euh ni aucune alternative envisagée à
la cérémonie le long de la scène si le
risque terroriste est trop fort et si
vous avez d déjà répondu j'ai dû oup au
moment où j'étais absente et je m'en
excuse mais c'est pour nous très
important en tant qu'élu de Paris
ensuite dans le contexte des tensions
sociales et géopolitique une
augmentation donc des attaques cyber a
été observé et le risque terroriste
reste élevé pouvez-vous donc nous
détailler également les dispositifs qui
ont été mis en place pour protéger
notamment les infrastructures physiques
mais aussi numériques du COJO et euh
pour aller très très rapidement sur le
Grand Palais dans le chantier on le sait
de rénovation est absolument énorme
est-ce que vous serez prêt dans les
temps voilà merci pour vos réponses
merci maintenant on vous laisse la
parole pour les réponses monsieur le
Président je vais peut-être commencer
par vous et et ça permettra de répondre
également à Madame Érin et puis ensuite
je reprendrai l'ordre des des
questionnements sur le la cérémonie
d'ouverture euh le travail sur
l'estimation détaillée des jauges la
jauge sur les kebas qui est sont les
quais payants par achat de billet et
ainsi que sur les ponts sur et la et
l'évaluation de la Jae sur les Koo qui
sont les billets gratuits et donc la la
prééservation gratuite sont en train
d'être finalisé autour du préfet de
police et avec le cojot pour les kebas
euh en tenant compte d'éléments qui qui
se sont précisés au fur et à mesure de
la construction du projet artistique et
de parade nautique euh impliquant un
certain nombre de choix sur des écrans à
positionner à tel ou tel endroit et donc
sur des réductions ou au contraire des
capacités qui sont prévu plus importante
sur le fait que comme vous le savez sur
les ko le choix qui a été fait et c'est
un peu la logique de la Ligue des
Champions si je peux me permettre de
simplifier c'est d'éviter des mouvements
qui suivraient finalement la parade et
qui viendrai se se converger et et créer
des risques de de de foule
euh en amont àx ité du Trocadero et donc
d'avoir des zones sur lesquelles les
prééservations seront effectuées
permettant
de d'éviter évidemment un
mouvement de de progression
massive et donc tout ça conduit
effectivement à des révisions
de de normes de de présence prévu et
donc de place y compris d'ailleurs avec
la question des bouinistes puisque sur
un certain nombre d'endroits le le le
maintien ou pas de ces boîtes conduit à
ce que que la vue soit
extrêmement contrainte en dehors de
toute question de sécuritaire bien
entendu soit très très difficile et
finalement extrêmement peu attractif
pour le public qui serait qui serait à
ces endroitsl enfin il y a tous les
positionnements tous les écrans vous le
savez il y a près de 80 écrans qui sont
prévus pour permettre une rediffusion
dans de bonnes conditions donc tout ça
conduit oui à ce que la jauge est en
train d'être légèrement revue pas
fondamentalement mais sans doute avec
des évolutions de l'ordre de 10 à 15 %
qui tiennent compte de ces évolutions
précises sur un projet final définitif
stabilisé voilà pour ce qui est de la
jauge sur le plan
B le dans dans matière de grands
événements il faut toujours réfléchir à
des hypothèses où il y aurait une
impossibilité mais actuellement d'abord
le Stade de France elle est cette ce
n'est pas un plan B soyons parfaitement
clair s'il y a aucune possibilité
d'utiliser Stade de France puisqu'il y a
déjà des épreuves qui sont prévues au
Stade de France et donc c'est pas pas
imaginable
donc le plan B est plutôt celui d'avoir
une adaptation du concept lui-même
autour de la scène et donc c'est ce
cette réflexion qui effectivement a été
évoquée par le Président de la
République et qui est en cours sur la
baignabilité c'est la même chose
d'ailleurs sur la question du Plan B moi
ce que je tiens à dire c'est que le plan
de de qualité de l'eau de beignade entre
la mer de Paris porté par l'Agence de
l'eau le préfet de région Île-de-France
avance très bien avec des résultats
remarquables qui se sont déjà visibles
effectivement euh il peut y avoir des
risques météorologiques que sur lesquels
il y a un vrai travail de planification
et donc avec toutes les conséquences
j'insiste là aussi un plan B ne se
décrète pas les épreuves qui sont
prévues dans la scène c'est des épreuves
notamment de triathlon le triathlon ça
suppose qu'on puisse courir prendre le
vélo et se baigner avec des points de
départ qui sont les mêmes et donc on
peut pas imaginer comme ça d'aller
déplacer parce qu'il y aurait une une
turbidit accrue de l'eau liée à une un
orage un autre endroit sans avoir en
même temps redéployer tout un plan de
circulation vélo et tout un plan de
course à pied compliqué et là le but
c'était précisément de le faire dans cet
espace donc le plan B il est plutôt dans
l'hypothèse de report de d'ajustement
des des dates des épreuves en tenant
compte du fait qu'on prévoit une météo
orageuse et compliquée certaines
journées en l'anticipant à ce moment-là
d'un jour ou deux ou au contraire en le
reportant d'un jour ou d'autre c'est
sans doute là qu'est la marge
d'adaptation en situation éventuellement
de critique naturellement voilà pour ce
qui est de la cérémonie et du et de et
de la
baéignabilité pour le reste monsieur
Savin insistait sur la nécessité que ces
jeux fassent l'objet d'une adhésion
populaire et d'une forte mobilisation
populaire je veux rappeler quand même
que le prix des billets 50 % des billets
sont à se rend à moins de 50 €. c'est un
événement s je parle des billets hein je
parle pas de l'hébergement mais je je
pour se rendre dans dans certains sites
il faut prendre le train quand on habite
dans le Gers si on veut aller voir des
épreuves qui sont à Paris il faut
prendre le train et c'est un cût
également quand vous allez aux Jeux
Olympiques dans d'autres Olympiades je
l'ai fait moi-même à titre personnel et
bien vous trouver des hôtels ou des
campings je me souviens très bien que
j'ai accompagné mon fils qui qui était
dans des épreuves à
on a logé dans un camping à 3h de
voiture fort sympathique d'ailleurs où
il y avait que des gens qui étaient là
pour les jeux et puis on y allait et on
passait la journée à Athènes et on
rentrait le soir avec mes enfants et
tout le monde était très content donc il
y a des solutions qui peuvent être
trouvées pas forcément dans des hôtel
pas forcément à Paris et dans une vaste
région qui a des capacités importantes
des bases de loisirs et des lieux dans
lesquels il y a sans doute des
possibilités par ailleurs c'est la
réalité c'est un événement historique
les gens sont prêts à faire un petit
effort aussi pour payer leur hôtel s'ils
veulent aller à l'hôtel mais
incontestablement il y a une demande
très forte qui va entraîner des tensions
et on ne peut pas contrôler complètement
le dispositif Airbnb ou hôtelier même si
il faut essayer de le moraliser au
maximum donc voilà la réponse sur le
reste pour les logements les volontaires
étaient par définition des volontaires
c'est-à-dire qu'il savaient qu'il
n'était ni payé ni euh héberger à part
quelques milliers d'entre eux sur les
45000 pour lesquels il y a eu des choix
ou par pour des raisons très spécifiques
mais pour les autres ils savaient qu'ils
se débrouillaient par eux-mêmes et on se
découvre beaucoup d'amis vous savez
quand on vient comme ça dans un type
d'événement on se rappelle que on était
avec tel étudiant je vois les médecins
les les services d'urgence pour les les
médecins urgentistes et cetera il se
débrouillent il y a des réseau et ils
viennent pour ces deux ou trois jours
deux ou trois nuits ils trouvent des les
gens trouvent des solutions pour un un
événement historique centenal qui n'est
pas un événement ordinaire et donc pour
lesquels on peut avoir ses contraintes
incontestablement de coût d'hébergement
c'est une réalité je ne Danie pas mais
pour les volontaires elle était posée
dès le départ et accepté par eux avec
l'envie de participer simplement à
quelque chose qui à leurs yeux n'a je
dirais presque n'a pas de prix et et et
la plupart ne vont pas payer
l'hébergement mais le trouver par des
relations enfin euh la mobilisation des
ministres sur les jeux que vous appelez
de vos vœux et particulièrement de la
ministre de éducation de la jeunesse des
sports et des jeux évidemment est
acquise tous les ministres sont
extrêmement mobilisé depuis plusieurs
mois ça va s'accentuer encore dans les
mois qui viennent en terme d'attention
de fixation d'orientation pour la
ministre des Sports et des jeux de
présence éventuellement sur les
événements de pilotage interministériel
organisé autour du Premier ministre le
les si jops du de conseil présidentiel
de conseil de sécurité on a un rythme
aujourd'hui de mobilisation politique de
l'ensemble du gouvernement qui est
extrêmement fort et dans lequel ça
s'intégrera pleinement je peux vous
l'assurer madame oua Castera pour pour
le reste colombe brossell évoquait le
sujet des transport avec beaucoup
d'autres après
elle et je veux redire que j'ai nous
avons tous conscience que au plan
national pour la SNCF pour les
transporteurs aériens ou pour ADP au
plan francilien pour les opérateurs de
transport accueillir des Jeux Olympiques
dans un pays comme le nôtre même s'il a
un excellent réseau de transport public
est un véritable
défi ce défi nous allons le relever dans
un schéma qui est assez propre à la
France tout de même et c'est pas le du
tout le schéma anglais où le schéma
anglais il y avait une collectivité
c'était le Grand Londres il y avait un
opérateur qui dépensait du Grand Londres
qui était London Transport et il y avait
un seul opérateur qui faisait d'ailleurs
aussi bien le travail de la solideo que
le travail de la dijop système anglais
le nôtre c'est celui d'avoir des
collectivités nombreuses d'avoir des
opérateurs regroupés dans une autorité
organisatrice de transport avec les
collectivités et tout ça n'est pas le
aussi simple mais néanmoins est
parfaitement adapté à réussir cette ce
défi à le relever il suppose et c'est
indéniable il suppose une communication
sur les transports qui soit claire qui
soit transparente que le citoyen se
sente partie prenante de ce défi et
accepte comme il l'a su le faire dans
d'autres périodes terribles pour nous de
de confinement ou autres qu'il accepte
d'adapter un peu ses horaires de choisir
des modes de transport qui soient plus
adaptés si on habite dans Paris ou dans
la proche couronne on peut dans certains
cas aller en vélo au mois de juillet ou
au mois d'août aux épreuves on a du coup
rajouté ça n'était pas prévu dans la
copie du tout un dispositifs sur des
vélos avec une mobilisation de toutes
les collectivités de depuis la région la
métropole les départements les communes
et avec l'état de financement de voie
olympique il y a 280 km de voie vélo
olympique qui sont réservés avec une
continuité des transports sur tous les
sites à part celui de ville peinte qui
est au débouché même de du RER mais sur
tous les autres il y a un accès en site
un financement des parkings avec des
gardes des gardes de parking des
concergeries donc tout ça permettra
d'utiliser pour une part peut-être 6 %
10 % selon les sites des acc ces vélos
dans d'autres cas il y a des
possibilités aussi pour les les
personnes qui habitent à proximité de ne
pas venir toutes en transport collectif
mais pour certains à pied en voiture et
enfin sur les zones les plus contraintes
certains ont évoqué la zone ouest on
peut évoquer la zone du Stade de France
on a un plan de transport extrêmement
fin réactif qui permet selon les heures
selon les jours selon les intersessions
c'est un travail
de je je dirais de Romain véritablement
quand vous voyez ce travail auquel je
participe mais qui est porté par IDFM
avec tout tous les acteurs ensuite il
faut considérer que ceux qui devront
partir bien du Parc des Princes on les
orientera sur le rerc parce que s'ils
vont en en masse sur la ligne 9 ou sur
la ligne 10 ces lignes ne pourront pas
absorber ce flux donc il faut les
accompagner il faut mettre de la police
pour gérer les carrefours avec le
boulevard exelem ous le pont du
gargilano l'entrée avec la SNCF et avec
des trains aussi nombreux que possible
pour prendre les flux faire ses calculs
de manière précise ouvrir plusut tôt
ouvrir 3h avant plutôt que 1h30 avant le
début des épreuve et inciter les gens
par un par ce travel dem management à
arriver avant l'heure et donc à lisser
un tout petit peu les pointes d'arrivé
ou de départ et cetera et cetera c'est
ce travail qui est en cours qui va
rentrer en dans le domaine public qui va
être partager puisque en principe dès la
fin janvier après que le préfet de
police a finalisé sa concertation sur
les périmètres de sécurité qui était un
facteur contraignant de cela où sont les
stations de métro quelles sont celles
qui seront ouvertes il fallait avoir
stabilisé tout cela quells sont les les
zones rouges les zones bleues c'est fait
maintenant on va pouvoir avoir ce
système d'information sur les transports
qui permettra à chacun de
s'organiser certains partiront à
l'extérieur de Paris s'il ne souhaitent
pas participer d'autres feront un peu de
télétravail d'autres auront d'autres
choisiront des horaires un peu décalés
les chefs d'entreprise seront mobilisé
pour accompagner cette cette souplesse
pendant les quelques semaines de l'été
etprs les deux semaines de de de fin
août et de début septembre voilà et donc
on a des moyens
euh réels par exemple sur la zone ouest
pour terminer euh des navettes
complémentaires nombreuses qui vont
rajouter à la ligne 9 à la ligne 10 euh
au vélo euh aux personnes qui arrivent
en proximité il y a aussi des navettes
qui conduiront à la Porte Dauphine à à
l'étoile avec des capacités des circuits
qui sont déjà planifiés c'est c'est cela
qui est en cours et qui sera ensuite
partagé avec les élus en premier lieu
mais c'est le cas avec la Mairie de
Paris bien sûr et qui permettra je pense
de de de gérer ces contraintes quelques
points simplement pour évoquer les
surcûts de sur les J et le financement
de l'État ces surcoup ne sont pas
aujourd'hui estimés je l'ai j répondu
tout à l'heure donc je ne reviens pas
dessus et sur euh euh le le le
financement des transports je précise
simplement mais vous le savez Messieurs
et Mesdames les sénateurs il y a eu
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs et
mesdames les sénatrices il y a eu des
annonces qui ont été faites il y a déjà
maintenant presque un an sur les
financements sur des crédits de l'état
des coûts spécifiques d'idfm liés au jeu
et donc qui ont permis de d'assumer ce
ces surcouts que vous évoquez on parlait
évidemment de plusieurs centaines de
millions d'euros je diraiis juste un mot
sur la tour des juges pour répondre à
Madame dearco et à vous madame la
sénatrice pour expliquer que la tour qui
a été finalement choisie par le le
représentant du gouvernement par le
président de du
gouvernement de de Polynésie avec
l'accord de l'État d'ailleurs et et du
cojot
surtout est la tour initiale
allégé modifiée pour éviter
effectivement un poids trop excessif et
avec une étude d'impact qui permet de
garantir l'absence totale d'effet sur le
corail donc ce point a été repris revu
permettra de d'être utilisable pour les
autres épreuves internationales qui
suivront les jeux dans les années
ultérieures comme il y en avait
précédemment et avec une tour des juges
en bois qui n'était plus viable et qui
se c'est clairement révélé comme non
adapté désormais y compris pour d'autres
épreuves que les jeux et donc c'est la
la seule solution pour permettre de
continuer à utiliser ce spot dans la
dans le dans les les épreuves à venir
pour le reste mentionné peut-être sur le
l'héritage de la solidéo monsieur
Ferrand y
répondra pour la
ns je mentionne simplement pour les
sénateurs de sa saintis que le point
d'étape sur le le plan 5000 équipements
a conclu à une consommation intégrale de
tous les crédits sur la fin de l'année
2023 le le plan de 300 millions d'euros
que le gouvernement a mis en place pour
2025-226 portera pour 100 millions sur
ces 300 millions et sur les 3 années sur
100 millions sur une reconduction du
plan petits équipements de proximité de
façon à récupérer si je peux dire les
dossiers qui étaient constitués et pour
lesquel on avait épuisé les financements
des 300 millions du plan
précédent enfin sur l'intelligence
artificielle oui le dispositif a été
testé à Marseille en particulier euh
lors de d'un match il ne l'a pas été à
ma connaissance pendant la coupe du
monde de
rugby voilà je crois que les autres
points intéressaient plutôt monsieur
frand alors
euh je vais les reprendre donc sur
Tahiti ce n'est pas un sujet solidéo je
désolé c'est un sujet direct de du cojot
donc j'ai pas grand-chose à à dire
dessus par rapport euh à à la question
de monsieur le sénateur law sur le le
devenir des équipements donc on
construit à l'occasion des des jeux où
on rénove à l'occasion des Jeux
12 stade ou gymnase et h piscines et en
fait on les a et les travaux qu'on fait
dedans correspond complètement au
besoins exprimés par les élus par
rapport à le besoin du territoire et
donc vraiment la manière c'est faite la
démarche c'est faite comme ça on part de
de du du besoin final on fait les
travaux dessus et le COJO nous a dit
nous on prendra les différents
équipements dans cet état-là et on
rajoutera les besoins des des jeux donc
euh les le les les équipements tels qui
seront livrés en 2025 après les Jeux
après ces travaux de reconversion
correspondent exactement aux attentes
euh des des élus par rapport à la à la
question euh de monsieur le sénateur
Ziad sur les enseignements alors euh on
on va on va travailler sur ce qu'on
appelle la transmission la valorisation
finalement qu'est-ce quels sont tous les
enseignements que qu'on tire je me
permettrai de de de de juste d'accentuer
sur un point aujourd'hui devant vous on
a été capable aujourd'hui de livrer ce
programme qui fait peu près 4 milliards
et demi d'investissements dans le cadre
législatif actuel on a appliqué tout le
code de de l'environnement tout le code
de l'urbanisme tout le code de la
commande public donc aujourd'hui on peut
faire dans le cadre juridique actuel le
plus grand projet d'Europe tel qu'il tel
qu'il a été fait et pourquoi est-ce
qu'on a été capable de faire parce que
le collectif et la gouvernance a été
extrêmement forte sous l'autorité du
digj j parce que le le le portage
politique s'est organisé autour d'une
société qui a été créée exprès pour ce
projet là la solidéo et qui disparaîtra
après donc nous on n'est pas en train de
chercher du chiffre d'affaires ou la
prochaine opération pour pour nous
maintenir on va disparaître c'est une
société de projet et le fait que ce soit
une société de projet nous a permis
d'avoir une gouvernance politique
extrêmement stable et centrée uniquement
sur le projet je pense que ça ça a
beaucoup changé le ça a beaucoup changé
à faire ça marche aussi parce que
l'ensemble des acteurs publics a
toujours mis le de les les sujets que
nous avons portés en haut de la pile
donc on a tout le droit c'est appliqué
mais que ce soit les collectivités les
différents ministères les préfets les
préfectures les services de l'État ont
toujours pris notre dossier en comme
étant un dossier prioritaire et du coup
nous ont donné des avis éventuellement
des avis négatifs on en a eu un certain
nombre tout de suite et c'est je pense
que le la la la différence c'est cette
capacité à coordonner l'ensemble des
acteurs publics et privés sous
l'autorité du djop et à ce que le le le
la construction des ouvrages olympiques
soit bien considéré comme un dossier
prioritaire pour l'ensemble des des des
acteurs publics mais on va développer
tout ça dans le cadre de la la
valorisation dont je dont je vous
parlais sur la question de Madame
laatrice Olivier sur les les zones
artificialisées et les émissions de
carbone alors sur les émissions de
carbone je ne sais pas parce que c'est
vraiment le COJO moi je peux dire ce que
j'ai fait au titre de au titre de la
solidéo des ouvrages donc vous avez vu
on atteint - 47 % ce qui est absolument
inespéré mais mais on l'atteint sur les
zones
artificialisées le les gros équipements
que soit le village olympique ou le CAO
ont été construits sur d'anciennes zones
industrielles complètement atrophisé
donc il y avait il y avait quasiment que
des des platanes des arbres d'ingénieur
des pont comme moi et c'est tout et donc
on a désartificialisé massivement ces
zonesl et donc recréé et réamener la
nature en gros entre le corridor de
biodiversité que constitue la scène et
les les les l'autre très grand corridor
de biodiversité qui sont le le faisceau
Ferré Nord donc sur le le le village des
médias qui qui a été construit en en
partie sur sur l'air des vents on a
urbanisé 6 hectares mais on a rendu à
l'état naturel les 13 hectares de
l'ancien terrain aux essences des armées
qui était tellement pollué qu'il était
interdit d'accès voilà et donc en fait
la balance elle est à + 6 en temp en
terme de de zone naturelle et donc ça
permis d'étendre notamment la zone
Natura 2000 qui était qui était là-bas
et puis par rapport à la question la
Catrice Evin sur le le Grand Palais sur
le grand est qu'on sera prêt dans les
temps alors à l'été dernier les sujets
d'inquiétude ne portent pas du tout sur
la nef donc les compétitions auront lieu
les sujets d'inquiétude le Grand Palais
c'est 30000 m² hein voilà à peu près de
surface de plancher qu'on rénove les
sujets d'inquiétude à l'été dernier
c'était sur les 1000 m² du salon
Alexandre 3 donc c'est les salons qui
sont en au premier étage qui regardent
vers la scène donc la climatisation du
salon Alexandre I et les le le
restaurant qui s'appelle loulou qui est
au premier étage quand on regarde
l'entrée premier étage à droite donc euh
à l'été dernier on on craignait de ne
pas être capable de livrer ça dans les
temps aujourd'hui on sait qu'on sera on
sera capable de livrer ça dans les temps
et qu'il y aura simplement des levées de
réservve qui auront lieu après le 19
avril donc aujourd'hui oui l'ensemble de
l'équipement sera livré au cojot le 19
avril qui était la date pivot avec un
certain nombre de levé de réserves qui
auront lieu après voilà monsieur le
Président Monsieur le délégé j'avais
juste un point pour confirmer à madame
la sénatrice que le COJO faisait un une
analyse environnementale et euh
si je peux dire impact durable euh de la
bonne gestion de son de l'événement avec
un objectif de compensation de bilan
carbone de - 50 % mais avec une partie
de compensation et pas simplement de
réduction et donc je voulais vous dire
que nous souhait-ons du côté de l'État
mesurer de manière différente l'ensemble
de l'impact des jeux notamment sur le
bilan carbone mais sur les autres
aspects également et que nous avons
lancé donc 14 études totalement
indépendantes à des confiés à des
organismes universitaires ou à des à
l'INC sur les bilan économique et je me
permets d'indiquer pour les travaux à
venir peut-être de la commission ici que
on peut vous adresser une note pour vous
dire où on en est de la l'élaboration de
ces études on parle d'un d'une situation
d'une observation de départ et ensuite
quel sera le résultat après les Jeux
donc on ne pourra pas avoir ce bilan
avant 2025 2026 même dans certains cas
mais par exemple sur les athlètes on
constatera les médailles obtenues Jeux
Olympiques paralympiques on constatera
ce qui a été fait avec les financements
ambition bleu là le plan
d'accompagnement et on verra si
finalement on peut estimer que le bilan
de ces
investissements ont été bien placés par
rapport aux médailles obtenues et même
chose dans beaucoup de domaines sur
l'économie l'impact territorial
notamment en sc mais pas uniquement et
ou sur le le carbone sur le d'autres
bilans environnementaux donc ce travail
objectif servira de base de de d'
analyse sur l'impact réel multi
factoriel de des jeux dans notre
pays merci Monsieur le Délégué Général
et Monsieur le Directeur Général de vos
réponses très précises aux nombreuses
questions évidemment on va continuer de
suivre avec beaucoup d'attention votre
travail et on on vous souhaite bon
courage dans cette dernière période que
l'on imagine très intense déjà merci
beaucoup je vais inviter mes collègues
bien sûr à rester puisque nous avons
encore à l'ordre du jour je vais juste
raccompagner nos
invités